day three of the candidates in
Yekaterinburg Russia it was the round
before a rest day and the eight
contenders were back to do battle for a
freshest win co-leader Fabiano Caruana
blitzed out some amazing preparation but
Dame Lauren defended like a beast and
won the game to keep himself in
contention in the tournament the players
are refreshed and ready to continue the
fight for the title round four of
exciting action coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
from Yekaterinburg Russia it's the
fourth round of the 2020 candidates
tournament to determine the Challenger
to bang Miss Carlson for all the glory
for the World Championship but first
they have to go through each other i'm
grandmaster alejandro meters here with
grandmaster yes sir sara one pleasure to
be here tell us it's been only three
rounds of the event but already some
scintillating stories no question about
it hello out alejandro hello everyone
and thank you for joining us for live
coverage of around for as Alejandro was
saying three action-packed rounds and it
was that third round especially during
the free day that I really thought about
a lot
specifically the game between ding Loren
and Fabiano what a game extraordinary
preparation bobby was met and rebuffed
by ding Loren who stood oh and two at
the time that he did this and his
tournament would have been absolutely
absolutely over but he fought back and
won it was quite a tale Alejandro let's
take a look at the standings rounds that
game to change things considerably
because solutely before that we had four
win four liters that would be a wait
time for first a four-way tie for first
between max Eva Sheila graph Yana for me
Archie and Wong how all of them through
their games so they moved up to two
points out of three but Fabiano karna
was relegated just a bit and it's half a
point away from the leaders currently
with Alexandra Grichuk both of them at
50% a nice giri here Alex anko and
England make a very tightly packed race
all of them only odd - one where the
difference between first and last is
currently one point right very very
close event very close and the format
it's a double round-robin in Russia that
means that every single player will have
equal number of whites and blacks that
makes it a fair tournament hundred
minutes for the first 40 moves 50
minutes for the next 20 and once you
reach move 60 you get another 15 minutes
for the rest of the game all throughout
you'll have a 30 second increments a
very
long time control right no draw offers
before blacks 40th move half a million
euros in prize fund but that pales in
comparison to even getting second place
to the tournament this qualifies you to
no world championship everybody's gonna
be playing here for just that spot
really nothing else exactly and the
schedule we are playing in a format of
three games an arrest a three games an
arrest day and of course the day is
round for the weekend is starting
tomorrow we'll have another round Monday
as well but Tuesday you can see the
green line there it represents the
breaks that we'll have that is going to
be a rest day yes sir absolutely and the
players after this rest day I really
expect them to bring it to today for
Round four well let's take a look at
some of the events and breaking news
that we have a front round four with
Maurice Ashley well thank you Alejandro
indeed the event so far has been
absolutely absolutely cantankerous crazy
games amazing preparation beautiful
endgame technique will we see more of
that today well the games have begun
they've been going on now for a couple
of hours and we don't have the same
kinds of crazy Rock'em Sock'em Affairs
that we've had so far this one game is
one of the more imbalanced games is
between ding Lauren and Aneesh Geary
ding Lauren of course one what it just
had to be wasn't the more heroic
defensive Affairs we've seen in a long
time and he's going to try to keep that
momentum going this position is not
exactly your wildest one ever and the
move
a4 has been played by a niche Giri of
course a niche wants to keep going
solidly until he could take his chances
because he is of course tied in last
place along with ding Lauren but players
who are not tied for lies in fact on the
flipside tied for first are these three
let's take them one at a time
Maxima vassella Grove the pride of
France he started off this tournament
with a draw against Caruana and then had
a boss win against king
and he wasn't even supposed to be here
but now with his draw against kiri he is
tied atop the leaderboard and nip from
the achi the Russian superstar now
number four on the planet he started off
with a win and an amazing win at that
against a nice giri we haven't seen
games like that in a while but he has
now settled down a bit and he has made
two draws against his Russian
compatriots Chris Chuck and Alex anko
and finally a surprise a bit of a
surprise number 7 seed in this
tournament but one of the finest players
on the planet wang hao he won a comeback
game against England in round 1 but what
a finish once he got his chance he made
the most of it then that draw against
giri he's got to be feeling like man I
should have won that one he'd be in
first right now but then a draw against
Chris truck and he is instead of being
clear first only tied but we'll see how
the game's transpired today not as crazy
as we said as the games from previous
rounds but you'd expect the players to
so slow down a little bit let's see if
they can find some chances as the games
continue Thank You Maurice and let's
take a look at all those pairings shall
we
of course we got to see that thing there
an onigiri game but a crucial one for
the standings is that first one Fabiano
Khurana vs. yang nippon-ichi the Russian
player at one of the tied for first
places one house currently playing
Carroll alex anko Maxine Michelle our
graph is in a complicated Berlin
struggle against Alexander Christian
which is becoming a bit sharper by the
second actually have to switch to that
one pretty quickly
exactly and that's going to determine a
lot of things Maxime with the white
pieces he likes taking this Berlin and
games he's one of the few players in the
world that's willing his wife just to
get right into this ending right into
the end game and of course we can pull
that game up because I do think it's
interesting but of course it's Christian
and what do we say when Christian plays
chess what do this time trust time
trouble
time travel is looming
he only has eight minutes left on the
clock Wow and strangely enough like a
lot of these Berlin ending games it is
actually double-edged for a position
that remarkably quiet it's it's
double-edged okay
a big repeat of our earlier game that
Grisha played against nepo it was like a
king age to remember the game went with
Mike before it was kind of strange
no no Maxine said look I played directly
yes let me beat your night but we saw a
trade the night came back to e7 it
really feels like they were just playing
it I'll attempt oh it does feel like
this is an fel game from a violent car
from yeah I think I've been told h4 is a
novelty I believe that game what King g2
which seems g4 was played in that game
I'm being told so that's some memory but
not exactly right g3 g4 previous outing
I am the L by the way yeah h4 okay with
not too big a change as far as I can
tell Knight d5 all looks very standard
now this move Bishop c1 okay basically
offering upon saying I want to keep my
Bishop and once you've played at h4
Bishop c1 then it's practice yes that's
for me it's very clear that MV I wanted
this position Knight a four by the way
is a nifty little move the knight gets
out of the way for some reasons I'm not
quite sure the engine didn't like 95
engines that are that's one of those
positions is very difficult to analyze
even with an engine because difference
between a zero point zero zero and the
other zero point zero zero can be very
subtle and only with some practical
knowledge of the position that you
realize while this position is actually
easier to play over the board of
compared to this one and it's real mass
to try to analyze this even with an
engine and that's why a lot of people
have been shying away from these endings
from design game
the subtleties required are really quite
confounding and nvl has been practicing
this kind of engine is for quite a while
now getting a ton of experience he's won
a couple of games importing games in
this position that's been able to create
some pressure well let's take a look at
the tactics rook f3 played with a very
stone called idea of going after this f7
pawn by the way do keep in mind there is
a latent mm discovered attack okay so
the even ideas like Knight f7 and Bishop
h6 do exist so be careful for them
Bishop d5 tempo against the rook f4
again all of these moves in this very
strange way are rather forcing and c2 c4
is a potential as well that explains the
move Knight b6 have you put the net on
c5 something like c4 might ask your
bishop where it wants to go right one of
these days yeah okay now there you go
everybody is teaming up against this
pawn on f7 and Bishop I think that a
very good move we got his rook of the
potentially dangerous h6 square and by
the way reminded white that g3 is
hanging in some variations rook f5 okay
five it's very direct just as well it
just wants to play aged five and move
the rook out of the G file that the
indirectly defense that pawn on g3
because yes so you can't take it once on
f7 because g3 is hanging with jack so
rook have five sets up they're very
purposeful as you say the move h5
pushing the rook so that Knight f7 is
possible the ship c4 trying to be as
irritating as annoying as possible the
talk of the work is not trivial it's
actually seems many times that you have
talked one of these trips and okay I'll
move it problem is that if you attack
this rook and I play rook dat suddenly
you have to contend with the fact that
rook do you want check will win your
bishop right so I really want to play h5
but rook f2 as you're saying invites
rook da and rook d1 so I mean it's
actually a very very double-edged affair
yeah okay but we have more news on other
games Maurice what's up indeed what may
end up
a big development in the game between
Caruana and napalm the Chi has occurred
take a look at this the engines wanted
to play some kind of equalizing move
Bishop to d6 maybe even Bishop to c5
which looks pretty remarkable given that
this D pawn is trying to race down the
board but this move Queen a 3 mm can be
met by a surprising rejoin dirt we see
the Queen trade of course is possible
but this pawn is hanging so you think
okay what is he going to do about that
but turns out he can completely ignore
it with the move Queen D 1 and also
avoiding this Queen on a3
you can't even offer a trade anymore and
the problem is there's a threat that
could happen soon after g3 Bishop f4 and
d6 that's the thing that block has to
avoid now you might say well what if he
just plays a bull at Bishop to d6 will
suddenly have a problem
Queen d4 that just chases your bishop
backwards you're gonna have to put it
back on their fate and now we can go for
the g3 idea no purpose or any weirdness
Bishop f4 is coming your piece is tied
down this Bishop is super tied down to
the square and White is dominant it's
got the mate problem the d6 threat and
black is going to be in big trouble in
this position actually dead lost so this
is a key move though to find in the
first place our retreating move it's not
doesn't seem like the hardest move in
the world to see as Queen takes a2 is
obviously death after d6 is pawn it's
just flying down the board so it's no
big deal for somebody like Fabi to
notice I don't have to trade Queens and
you can't take my pawn will if ride
Queen d1 I think the odds are quite high
absolutely it looks like a very nice
move in fact yes let's go through this
game from the beginning right because
how did we get to this kind of any game
yeah okay well first of all as we know
yawn is died in the wool green fell
player and one of the nice things for
players that are looking at their
opponents yeah well there's two group
plays we must have something I guess
then we're gonna play d4 exactly and
there's MBL as well and I'm Fabio I'm
theory if
and Gary and fabbi used to be so
whenever I get whenever I see games
between two top-notch players who played
the same opening I'm really intrigued
yes because I'm sitting there saying
okay Fabi loved to play the Greenfeld
himself
so what does Fabi think is the most
dangerous line against the Greenfeld and
oh well first of all we get the
classical felt these days people playing
Bishop d2 right I don't know Bishop g5
and Bishop a lot more for little
sidelines yes the sidelines seem to be
dominant even h4 by the way side lines
seem to be more immediately I mean boom
h4 some great games being played in
those positions amazing but okay what
happened oh it's the classical classical
but I think people I've been really
exploring this Bishop b3 Knight of three
type setups exactly or Bishop III Queen
d2 I've seen quite recently I think I
want to call it the modern for the
modern classical even that makes almost
no sense buddy yes but the Bishop c4 /
92 oh this is good old school stuff yeah
that's cool stuff so the funny thing is
I was actually raised on the old school
stuff so now I'm really really intrigued
yes 96 and yes very very standard should
be three and now b6 now here there are
Queen c7 there are other moves for well
you got Bishop obviously very familiar
as it was the World Championship matches
between Kasparov and Karpov of course
where Gary would play Knight a5 and
Karpov captured on f7 and then they
played quite a number of games in those
World Championship matches in the
problems the computers got invented and
we realized it was just bad for luck
exactly a man came Bishop and there was
this line of play which was also yeah a
real it was all the rage for quite some
time and I remember Grand Master Larry
Kristensen really enjoying these kinds
of attacking yes yes okay but b7 b6
certainly has its the modern way of
playing this position exactly it's I
wanted
say usda-approved as in the
theoreticians fine b6 to be one of the
best ways of playing captures on c5
wasn't there there's more than a few
games I think our Ronin with White has
taken on c5 and I think after you take
on c5 Queen c7 is exactly correct
exactly so trust me when I say this is a
really really well explored but Queen d2
mainline so all of these moves really
struck me is main line until we got to
well yeah
h4 is the novelty of the game every
three had been played before and I
believe that there are quite a few games
I want to say about 20 or 25 grand
master level games in this position yes
but h4 seems to be all the rage it
doesn't really matter where the groove
will do you play h4 it just seems that
at some point you should play h4 and the
more I analyze this type of group of
positions the more I myself realized
that Age 4 is so useful for a white it's
like a really annoying move for the
second player too because White's making
lifts right but he's also trying to be
irritating and just are you gonna play
h5 and this is one of the positions
where you can see the advent of engines
engines love this h4 h5 trick and I
think for a long time in the grew fold
this was considered to be completely
innocuous it's that you put the pot on
h5 and so what you can't open the HDH
file there's no rook on h4
right even if there was a wreck on h1
you're not gonna mate black you don't
made if you in Cairo just by opening the
H file right but people realize it's not
the point
actually off of zero and Leela and all
these modern engines and the new
versions of starfish they love putting
the pond age sex right just cramping
down black style saying it's worth the
three tempo yeah it takes me to get the
pawn all the way there and you can see
in this positions that father even
allows the trade of a bunch of pieces
right he plays a move h6 netbook even
has the option of going into an endgame
of three more pieces against three minor
pieces and by trading Queens at this
moment at this moment as a first for
this exact position fabi's played
instantly
is all prepped Wow and it's actually
very unpleasant I woke up this morning
and I was getting ready trying to
analyze the position of it and I didn't
find any quality that was easy or
straightforward for a buck it felt like
black could defend the end games if you
sat down and you really thought about it
you would defend an unpleasant position
but then I thought a couple of things
first of all this is yummy Poochie
since when is jana from you actually
known to grab an end game both hands sit
down and defend raggy read that that's
what bingler n does that's what
sometimes favi does exactly that's not
the aisle that we come to appreciate
with no he likes a lot of pieces he
likes counter balances he likes chart
positions he likes to get a preparation
like what Geary did and shred it over
the board right he likes those
complications but this one I thought was
like a very clever position because it's
more or less two results why it's a bit
better in most 10 games and he'll never
really be defending yes you know that in
the group of this pawns on a 7 and B 6
they can become dangerous in the in the
long run you've always seen them you
know push down and create a three but
right now they're very far from it the
knight only fights misplace the bishop
on their fates not doing the usual
controlling of Anand patrolling the long
diagonal that's right the end gives that
you think where these pawns are
dangerous usually involve rooks where
they're already sitting behind the pawns
here they're already traded and and yet
for all of the things that you're
pointing out yeah you know if you went
back into the 50s and 60s 70s or 80s
let's say that's fine
yeah but they wouldn't really appreciate
the pressure that they six pawn is
putting on blacks position Maurice jump
in here well I'll let you guys get back
to analyzing that but I just want to
quickly make a note of something that's
happening in the game between Winehouse
and Caroline Alex anko in this position
let's go actually was this moment he
played Bishop f1 Queen takes b3 and Wang
house sat here for a while and he's been
thinking and thinking and I'm wondering
why is he taking so long
well obviously he has two choices either
Knight takes a pawn takes so he goes
into a deep tank and he comes back out
and decides finally to play pawn to
which of course offers a straightforward
trade on the a line and so his opponent
played rook takes a won and he goes into
a deep think again what's going on it
looked like two very simple moves and
you figure after you've decided to play
863 that you're ready to capture back on
a one when the guy trades and he's back
in a deep thing here we wondering why
well rook takes which takes over the a
file is met by rook to c8 and now black
his foot thinking about putting pressure
in the position and blacks basically
fine here so it's surprising that he
went for this big thing by the way after
rook takes a what if his bishop takes
well he might have one of the a far but
not black takes the a file that didn't
seem that hard to calculate when he was
back on deciding to play a takes be
three over Knight takes but now he's
here to what looked like straightforward
exchanges has sent him spiraling hid to
about wasting about it looks like 30
minutes maybe on the clock you you
wouldn't think that this is what he
would be deeply thinking about not some
wild complications anyway back to you
guys you know that that is actually
quite funny yeah taking a long time on a
one of two captures and then taking
another long think of one or two
captures it does seem strange well very
back to the position you're saying that
understanding previously was that this
enemies they should be okay right um I
think that technically they should be
okay right but they'd requires a
precision for blocker a little bit
playing against the opponent a little
bit playing the position a little bit
saying look it is a bit better for white
in the long run you do have to defend
right so that's here I think I might
have again young being right the type of
player that you had mentioned he likes
the complications was not eager to trade
Queens I think I might have been the one
trading Queens here as black
he played Bishop and then D 5 e 7 e 6
Knights III and that was the end of the
possibilities of trading Queens exactly
now you have to play either a queen type
of endgame or some kind of minor piece
endgame in which white is the one
proposing the exchange of Queens because
you can no longer force it exactly he's
true
this defense of the pawn on d5 now white
is actually well this night on a5 is
being uncomfortable I think it's time to
play Knight c4 and this is a very
curious decision here by Fabiana he
thinks for 15 minutes after the move
Knight c4 and there's in my view - clear
moves here you can either move the
bishop on e3 or you can take on e6
that's where that would be the moves
that more or less I considered and then
he takes on c4 and sometimes when you
see a bishop you really don't want to
trade it for a knight exactly but he has
a very specific continuation in mind
it's a resource
it's very forcing Queen D does a very
nice move notice that you can't play
Bishop b4 in this position it's just a
attempting yeah which is very exactly
thank you very tempting move the knight
being pinned yeah a problem you take on
e6 and again the power of the part of h6
you can't actually take on c3 there's
Queen d8 followed by e7 no perpetual so
you're just loose yeah so just to
complete the line as you were pointing
out Queen takes and here do you want to
play this or do you want to take on f7
there isn't there's no e7 there's Queen
81 and 25 so you got 2007 side right but
you are picking up back the piece and
you're picking at the end of the day
you're very happy with white yes after
for example King g8 and that would
actually move that's they've been mated
yeah Wow
okay sorry so after Queen d7 I have to
actually block with a bishop now you're
taking and well what else to do do you
think this was a part of his prep - I
mean it's no I don't think so because by
this part he had already thought for
quite a while okay so I we're assuming
that position is very very advantageous
for white it sure looks that way do it
so he wasn't afraid of Bishop before so
he took and then Knight takes d5 now
yeah Knight f6 check is really very
frightening the knight had to go and
that was where we've got to this
position and after Queen a3 far we spent
a considerable amount of time about 15
minutes to think and he played the move
Queen c2
not that we knew one which was the one
that Maurice was
recommending I like the move Queen d1
because I wanted to keep this pawn you
know the option of playing pawn to d6
but it looks quite challenging to me I
mean the plot is the same you go G
before and at some point you start
pushing you use the made threats to
combining the made threats on g7 yes
with me ideas like Queen c6 and d6 in
pushing the pawn so and basically I see
this as being because a position really
where the past define d5 pawn is
dominating all the action I mean that is
the most dangerous pawn in the position
in black as the one who has to maintain
if he's able so not a very nice position
I think for you not so much I think
Queen c2 and you started calculating
things and some of the reasons that even
a fast player like that from yeah she's
thinking you can see that he's been
thinking 15 minutes here I have 10
minutes there that last couple of moves
because I move like for example Bishop
c5 which is a movie 1 as you want
it might lose on the spot we're not
saying that it might be a little bit
worse for luck it might just lose on the
spot good take on see if I force you to
take with the Queen and then you have to
analyze this this endgame or the end of
the endgame I think the endgame has just
lost for a block holy smokes it's just
because you have to you get to see for
first oh well then it's over yeah and I
think the Tempe with and this is what
the players are calculating right the
Tempe on both sides from what I can see
and while the engine is telling me I'm
right yeah well there should be a way to
zooms wrong block in this position
exactly and once you pick up the c5 the
pawn there are stats easy yeah the rest
is trivial oh ok that was funny because
I wasn't even thinking about the end
about the Queen I was thinking that he
was playing queen bee - no threatening
the checkmate king of eggs if they're
winning they're winning this is actually
what's going through my mind was like
why you were as black why you reluctant
to trade the dark square Bishop it does
have a drawback
yeah g7 square so before we go into a
deeper analysis let me remind the
viewers that
we do have a phone number for you to
call if you want to join here in the
conversation eight questions call us at
3 1 4 3 6 1 5 4 6 5 lines are open and
we'll be happy to take questions now we
really enjoy it when the audience comes
in with some really good forms and we've
actually have excellent was Queen Sita
Queen a5 plate and the bowls you seem to
be very excited about that
well the engines are going crazy right
now this Queen a5 move simply looks
deplorable after what it what move Queen
back to d1 again this time even stronger
because the Queen no longer guards the
d6 square so White has gained energy off
this move the Queen was at least on the
diagonal you could say well at least
these six is not a threat but now d6 is
a threat and the idea is with the Queen
here Queen before Maybin better to
control to possibly have a Queen e1
check but make sure you maintain control
over d6 but this move Queen a5 it makes
the Queen seem woefully misplaced the
threat of d6 on the board
the threat of putting a queen on d4 on a
dominant diagonal potentially it looks
like he's virtually forced to play the
move Bishop to d6 not exactly what she
wanted to do given that this diagonal is
still such a problem and now the move g3
and Queen DeForest coming Bishop f4
could potentially come this one is
starting to look extremely dangerous
maybe he didn't find Queen d1 the first
time in Queen c2 but will he find it now
Queen d1 is a monster move and will
absolutely give white an advantage Wow
plus an endgame I love the move Queen d1
and this is their match ups the only
wind that Yan has against I mean far the
only decisive game was from the
Grantchester uncurl show where young was
completely busted I came out like a
zombie from dead
managed to win that game that was like
amazing around yeah that's exactly right
I remember that and Yan started that
tournaments so very very well crushing
yeah like three out of three okay after
Queen a5 Queen d1 why is this game so
important well because of our standings
again let me just remind everybody on is
coming into this round tied for first
with +1 that be at 50%
they couldn't reverse places should fat
be pick up a point and after that loss
to dinkler in I mean this tournament
just keeps you know topsy-turvy churning
each and every round I love this movie
well yeah I realize I need a little bit
more coffee because cleanly one yeah
they should be six and I was thinking
wow legging for checkmated one and Bobby
Fischer in his Bobby Fischer teaches
chess book would be the first person to
point out to you why that didn't work
but will be playable I mean we reckon
can be played but I was thinking Quincy
for also looks very nice to me and could
I also Queen c-46 I really like until I
realize that Queen takes a two is
possible and that's when I stopped
liking the move and let's just continue
because we you can't play t6i pick up
the palm for free I go Queen a one check
and this is the tactic that was why
Maurice has been drumming the table for
g3 yes and King g2 and Bishop f4 now
after this check oops
yeah you picked up my beauty no there's
nothing else to say so that was why you
were luck reluctant to play Queen c6 you
don't want to lose the a to pawn between
c4 I like Queen c4 just because it kept
control over the entire board yeah and
you're still you buy a g3 King g2 I
Kentucky control over the c5 square so
that doesn't ever go there the drawback
I can imagine from White's point of view
is that these pawns on a 7 & b6 that
don't play a factor
so maybe Queen C for your encouraging
black to you know I don't know try to
utilize the pond
right but I was trying to coax you okay
playing b5 the reason I don't like b5
for black is that as soon as I entered
the eighth-ranked you've given up the c5
square phone okay that's a different
matter
one the pawn was on b6 just a quick
announcement the he can sound them of
Queen d1 so this is largely irrelevant
but which is a great move here's the
thing black does have this queen yeah
the point of Queen e1 yes is that you
can play queen yes mmm nice yeah sir we
have a guest with us a phone call from
Tennessee tell us your name and your
question yeah this is hear me all right
yes all right cool um this is Michael
Shoei I live in Jackson Tennessee and
you know watching this for the past you
know three or four days I guess they're
thinking in terms of like the kovat 19
and when we think about how for example
the NBA is on pause and potentially
other sports are on off with the chat's
productions do you guys have is there
any real big let's say opportunities
especially in time like this to really
get on cable if the production is really
good and when works like MVA have been
on pause for a minute it's just being
like a big opportunity to really put you
know I think you guys did a great job
and have a great quality so it's curious
what you offer in that content well
Michael first of all thank you so much
for the question and the answer is yes
yes the internet streaming chess lends
itself perfectly for online lessons
online coaching online entertainment and
as we came into studio today you were
telling me about your wife who's taking
salsa lessons online that is pretty
crazy when you think about it chess is
so well-suited to the online spectator
we've been doing this for a while
without having people tell us you know
you have to
party right we can analyze we can
transmit our crew is relatively small so
we're allowed to gather right but we
would love it we would yeah and the
numbers for this tournaments I mean you
were mentioning how many people in China
a lot of them are being still in
quarantine right
even some of the major cities are just
starting to resume normal life a million
people watching
yes candidates who you fond and paying
over there in Russia are giving
commentary in Mandarin and a million
Chinese and I believe it was day one by
Laila yeah a meal and it may have been
picked up a lot more right because
that's the way these chess tournaments
go as they go on more and more people
become aware of it so yeah we think that
chess is great that the Internet is
perfect for us and we would love to do
more so anybody wants to come along with
some kind of encouraging offers here
Maurice do you have no no not for the
moment he's looking something up but I
take a look at another of our tournament
leaders yeah just to finish on the
Saudis I think there was a lot of
controversy surrounding the candidates
because yes it should happen so hanging
over the heads of a lot of players right
whatever the correct decision was
probably it's it's gone it's not the
tournament is happening right and it is
an opportunity for chess no question we
have probably one of the most important
events going on right now in the entire
world so many things got canceled right
well we still have the pleasure of being
able to see candidates unfold yeah
without really a major hiccup they're
relatively secluded in Yekaterinburg
they're taking extreme precautions right
with the players yeah some of them are
not happy one of the moon withdrew
there's a lot of controversy service for
shirt around this tournament this will
go down in history as a controversial
candidate it's no question no questions
about it I mean people will no matter
who wins this tournament people will say
this was hanging over the players heads
was this really the best player we could
have chosen right but this is where we
are this is a production we
sort of the games we have and the show
must go on and but having said all of
that and I I agree there's a lot of room
for criticism
man what a show we've been fated to I
mean those first three rounds just just
wouldn't ask more from this tournament
and ding we're in I mean I think you use
the word and it's not her purpley heroic
unbelievable I couldn't I mean we will
go and we will talk about great
comebacks and you start oh and - and the
number two player in the world comes at
you with some of the most prepared
wickedness his world has ever seen and
you withstand it it's great stuff that
is just great stuff let's pick up on one
of our tournament leader Wang Hao he is
playing against obviously the lowest
rated player in the tournament the 8th
seed and you know he could have started
to know I mean Wang Hao yeah one could
be you could be having an amazing
amazing tournament right now he could be
like streaking away from the other
players and of course when he's playing
the lowest rated seed he like Fabiano
before him is looking at him saying I
got a I've got a target you 95 ok so
first of all the rook has posted nicely
and aggressively but it can easily get
kicked back 98 is an important resource
if the rook could stay there was stable
yes on a 7 it's really annoying at some
point you kind of run out of moves
yeah and the worst part is that even the
the rook on b8 might get pushed away and
that's a real problem because that's the
only way you're holding that part of
this happen right now with the rook but
but because of the move very important
defensive move Knight c8 that rook is
going to get the boot but first place at
girl suss and then and then I got it
would get rid of this knight on e5 get
my pieces into the game a little bit
Bishop b5 thanks to the bishop on b2
please says well please take on e5 which
would lengthen my diagonal of the bishop
on B to the bishop the d4 square could
be an ideal if you don't what else are
you looking at
I'm not taking on d7 immediately but it
does feel a bless him to leave the night
there I feel like running out of mousse
and I would love to analyze this
position for a little bit longer Chris
Kirk has a minute 40 left no I want to
see if that game has sharpened oh my
goodness a minute 40 left the last few
moves to some okay remember when we left
it we left it you attack me oh and VL
had hep-c for Rocky one ahead sacrifice
Department age five that make sense
Katie not the work G for defense the
pond okay but for that pawn sacrifice is
really advanced track HHA now Maurice is
yelling apparently the a4 is very
dangerous
why hey for very more okay all right I'm
just having a heart by three seems
problematic there is Bishop a3 there's
ePHI v6 oh that right in the position
okay so let's okay right okay
so I start with a check I assume I have
to play east six oh you want to go eat
six first okay well I've got a play f6
there's no choice because let's just
show that is the bishop on e6 is in a
absolute pin you cannot recapture on f7
so f6 okay something like this no
because it's not a hand waving that way
my poor Marie said this is great he has
a microphone problem so yeah actually
muted I now know the secret of how to
pull pull out his microphone cord and
that's it chance to join the show real
trouble brace yourself
okay f6 hold on you haven't killed me
yet he says something like rookie for
from the hand signals I understand rook
Evo you dr. Bishop Michael it's not
working for because the end is just
screamed at me yeah but a poor this is a
very challenging movement rook aged six
seems like he was a mistake he should
have played more aggressively did Griff
shook but this move a for releasing the
bishop into the game and now all of the
pieces you saw this activity by Maxime
he's gotten his chance by the way back
here after this move Bishop to c4 he did
have to back down because of the rook d8
idea the engines absolutely love that
and he played rook e1 and still rook d8
was the best move but after King 87-85
ribcage 6 g 4 and now this move rook to
h8 that's what happens when you're in
time pressure you can't figure out all
the niceties and you feel like let me
just make a solid move but blacks pieces
now are much less active than whites and
especially with those rooks still in the
corner let's get back to this a4 move
the reason why a for such a wonder guys
is this will rookie four really comes
out of nowhere you you are after that
bishop and the bishop is tethered to the
F pawn what that means is you can't play
a move like b5 yeah you know I'm
protecting everything because I'm
killing this guy this guy goes down and
then I'm taking this one and it doesn't
matter where you go this is going to be
painful rook takes Knight is streaming
pawn you can't fix the position fast
enough this bishop will enter this
Knight is headed to the e6 square and
you can see this position is that so the
main idea a beautiful
after you see you realize the problem is
the bishop on c4 you're able to play
this move because you want to play this
anyway and you just simply can't take
because it's all about this piece this
piece is holding the entire position
together so a very straightforward idea
but being buttressed by tactics so this
move a4 very strong indeed now he can
play much more solid lead Oh take the
pod just back up kid tag
here let you just not have any e6 action
and just go on the defensive after King
to d7 rook d1 check can be played now
you have to start playing moves like
Knight to d5 and have the rook drop back
this one is sharp let's not even say it
and it's a lot of moves left you like to
find all these defensive moves but first
of all nvo has to find the move a fork
thank you
welcome back write out some good stuff
you were sharing there that rook takes
e4 that was right but the more you
analyze that you think oh my god I've
said it's just crushing you take g7
takes you've written icon these six yes
sir we do have a call from Rhode Island
so welcome to the show please give us
your name on your question my name is
Ian Desmond and I love you guys you're
doing a great job I teach kids just in
schools after school I'm retired banker
and one things I tell them tell the kids
in the chess pyramid is that even at the
top they make mistakes
oh yeah grandmasters chess champions
remember Petrosian hunger rook against
Bobby Fischer once but but my question
to you guys is especially yasser who
lose all lose games are like a Bible for
me in the gym so even though I don't
know if anyone plays the classical
variation anymore
when Wang Hao missed miss turkey crucial
winning move rookie two and of course we
had Cara wanna who a lot of you know was
a top player you miss I played that
movie when I saw these moves live with
you guys he played aged six I was like
86 and then he didn't he didn't put the
bishop I mean those would have been
articles from automatic motion me how
difficult is it for a high level
Grandmaster to recover from an
inaccuracy like that first of all Steven
you're a hero on the front line there
anyone who's teaching chess in their
retirement years you know
salute thank you so much for them and
then for your question I think this is
like
one of the most difficult things not
just as a chess grandmaster but for
everyone to keep your objectivity even
when you just made a mistake and you
know yeah I made that mistake but you've
got to remain calm and just look at the
position now forget about the past
so hard to do alejandra how do you deal
with it I think it's one of the toughest
things to do even when you are a very
high level players making a mistake it's
not so much that the mistake is gonna
change things in the position but
psychologically getting used to the fact
that this move was bad and therefore the
evaluation has changed and a lot of
those things and we were mentioning this
in one house game that he had that
clarity of mind to stop going for the
win right and to actually just take the
draw say okay I've messed this up let's
calm down no reason to push this
unnecessarily let's just make the draw
because that's what I've made I've made
mistakes and this is where I've landed
and I think that's incredibly
problematic no matter what level you are
it's easier to play games where you
don't make mistakes sure you don't have
to change your mindset but we're human
so we make mistakes all the time all the
time doesn't matter how strong you are
chess gets more complicated it gets
faster you know where you compare
previous errors to now you're buying
stronger opposition yes you're playing
better defenders and you are more likely
to not be able to finish off an attack
you're more likely not to be able to
defend a tough position and having that
mindset that this was a mistake now this
is the truth of the position that really
separates some great players some some
pretty good players even pretty good
grandmasters 27-hundred that have a lot
of problems adjusted right now let me
ask you more specifically and drill down
20800 yes number two player in the world
Fabiano has just played some of the most
gorgeous preparation of all time coming
home with a big fat doughnut well how
does he get his mind overcome that
that's a tough one I think team 5 was
lucky that there was a rest day yes
that's a beautiful time to recover
psychologically not push things
sometimes you play on inertia in chess a
lot of the time especially when you have
rounds after rounds and you see that a
lot in rapid and blitz chess when we
have the
tournaments where you lose one and you
lose five right and the reason yeah you
go down on on some kind of tornado and
just it just runs through you right you
don't think about what happened you
don't stop and having the rest day it
gives you that ability you know I don't
know if they're taking walks but you
recharge jump in here Maurice your
difficulties in staying objective
staying cool man this particular topic
the callers brought up we could
literally be on for the next thirty
forty five we can remember stories from
our careers I mean there's so much here
and there's so much psychology and chest
I'd like to make first before I get a
little drill a little deeper the first
point that's really important to
recognize is that back in the day we
really thought of the strongest players
in the world virtually as God's I mean
you saw a beautiful game by tile and
then you see gains by Fisher and
Kasparov this is just like gold this
this is almost like you couldn't
possibly improve on these moves then the
darn computer show and the computer
started looking back at those games and
it go man do you have any idea how many
weak moves were being played the
defenders were defending like garbage
they had just done this the position
would have been equal and then you
realize they weren't quite gods they
were just superhuman they were not the
average human beings they were also
making mistakes that's why someone like
Garry Kasparov would make it a habit
after every single game lose of course
when definitely so look and see where
did I mess up I didn't did I play
perfectly or did I make mistakes and
usually he would find mistake you see
Gary analyzed in the informants and he'd
say yeah this move was not the best move
this was not the best move okay he
didn't play the best response now I
played a brilliant seat the rest was
perfect but anywhere he could look
today's players are aware of that they
are not gods they don't play perfect
Booz I don't care who you are including
Magnus Carlsen even his best games he's
gonna make that slight off move he wants
to improve and so that's the reality you
have to face and with that in mind that
your psychology should be
you realize it's not that easy for me to
play great chess all the time and
sometimes I'm gonna have great prep and
screw-up and by the way the thing about
that great prep Alejandro I got to do
something that normally I don't do I got
to agree with you I got it
then I that I was that I miss evaluate
the situation and that's the one with
ding Lorraine how you said how great
ding Lorraine played and I said well
Fabi didn't play his best but what I
realized when I was thinking about it
yesterday was Bobby sacrificed two pawns
for a strong initiative that gives a
huge responsibility on the person who
sacrificed no matter what position
appears on the board now yeah you've
gotten the preparation yes you have the
initiative but if it's a fresh position
you now have to follow through because
guess what
you're down to pawns now the guy might
have a lot to do to fix this position
but you're still down two pawns so if
you don't show it you're gonna end up
losing the game and that's what ding
Loren did dangler and said show me
exactly what you've got when we go out
of your preparation and now we're just
fighting for our lives and that's where
ding Loren proved to be superior to Fabi
in that concrete battle marvelous game
just simply Marvel's an awesome game by
the way we have another call yes I
believe from Virginia again your name ok
I wanted to ask any of the commentators
alpha zero and their offspring are they
or its offspring they're really bringing
something brand new to the game of just
have there been players that is played
like that and they're now being
recognized
and I also wanted to tell ya sir as a
music professor 20 years ago his
instructional CD was the first one that
I bought and I've always cherished it
well thank you so very very much it's a
great question a four-night takes a four
played in the game between
mvl and oh whoa Maurice I want you to
keep an eye out on that he has not only
a rookie for yet but we're gonna have
our eyes on that while we answer the
call
oh please everyone most familiar with
chess engines alpha zero doesn't have
any direct offspring I just want to say
that because alpha zero is not a public
engine so people don't actually know the
ins and outs of alpha zero but the idea
of how alpha zero works did give rise to
a new generation of chess engines you
could say it's the off stream not direct
but in a way indirect I would say
offspring of alpha zero and those are
called Liva
that was the first big engine that
thought the way off as you did and was
commercially available and I have to
tell you as somebody that was working
for the 2018 World Championship
it turned just upside down right we had
to go through all of the variations we
looked at and see dust really really to
everything and some of them were just
dead some of them are issues we had to
just throw them out just grab this file
set it on fire
I've got a USB throw it into the river
because that variation is rad yes it was
just did not work at all Wow
so to simplify yes it has changed tress
pretty clearly inserting variations and
there's a lot of new ideas that we
really like the reason that we say the
pattern h6 like alpha zero is because
this idea of putting pawns on h6 against
rancheros was really underestimated for
a long time it's one of the many
positional factors that you see it
doesn't really care that much that the
pond is weak it just thinks it's a bind
the space advantage is really worthwhile
and the bishop on g7 really
have another squared usually my just
wants to be on g7 and another one is a
peace activity it greatly greatly values
peace activity over material more so
than other engines right in positions
where stockfish would say you know I
have a pawn Lila would be just your post
worthless I have activity I'm good just
gonna crush you and sometimes it's right
sometimes it's wrong but it has changed
the way we look at dynamics in the game
so the answer is absolutely yeah and I
for me when I saw alpha0 play for the
first time I realized there was an alien
life-form and that was it Maurice jump
right on it well we are looking at some
good alien chess right now but it's
gonna be some straightforward stuff and
he missed it oh my goodness rookie 4 was
completely winning there was no doubt
about it this move was crushing to take
this bishop that we talked about this
this sacrifice rook takes c4 that would
have done the job no question about it
because you're hitting f7 you're
crashing through the other move Bishop
to e6 tricky dicky looking to exchange
here and take you could have my knight
but I'll take then take on h5
unfortunately the Knight takes pawn
takes hitting the rook looks great
Bishop check King back I'm still hitting
the rook this is what is so deep this
line like I said it would have required
some serious depth on Maxine's part
because now he has to find the move rook
to f3 preventing the knight from going
to c3 and now the knight is under attack
white is down to full pawns
the knight leaves with tempo and now
rook to f4 rookie f4 and only now is the
combination clear only now rook f7 will
happen and you cannot stop what's going
to happen to your position it's just
going to be pure tsunami as the rook on
the 7 will demolish everything this is
how DP have to go in the line and he
missed it but that would have been
winning but we are seeing other moves
appear on the board at the moment after
Knight takes a 14 said he played this
check and c5 and the movie 6 and he's
just playing a pace but gristick finding
now all the defensive move and the
engine saying now it is
perfectly fine for black he missed his
opportunity what a chance for Mike
seemed to go to +2 and he didn't see I
still don't get it you could help me out
because if you take on c5 where it where
is the defense I don't have it with me
takes you can go to maurices board you
take on c5 you take with midnight ship
yes with the bishop
okay yes position mm-hmm this is fine
for black well all he has to do is
defend this and I take on c4 you take on
c4 you take on do you fight way to play
rook c5 rook c+ and give is fine for
black I take one g5 in threatening rook
takes g7 what on earth you're only
threatening this right so let's let's
keep going only threatening my take on
g7 no if you take on G so okay that's
never gonna happen that happen he's got
his this is gonna start racing and you
oh you only have this pass pawn you
haven't made anything here yet he
definitely has this one than going down
the board have enough and it's amazing
the rooks going to always challenge and
this rook will always challenge this
roof the engines giving triple zeros in
this line now you know what it feels
like when you're not standing next to
the engine you're sitting here at the
table and you're going wait a minute
this looks so good I could play rook f5
rook at seven my I've got my passport on
the six rank
I mean why aren't I winning right zero
zero zero it looks crazy both their
party poopers look the reality is maxi
missed a golden chance for that golden
chance was one one of those lines
remember the end of it that movie
remember when when Kuro miss Bishop
takes g6 and the world said he must be
weak he afterwards he said I did see
Bishop g6 I did calculate but I couldn't
go far enough I didn't see he's fine he
had to CH and all those variations here
Mac seems yes you played a great move
but you have to see rookie four to start
you have to realize that
b5 yet the SAC ok Maxime could see that
but it
he sees this movement he realizes okay
is it this check this doesn't work it's
this check that does the job and now
play this move you have you still
haven't won anything and only at the end
of it do you come to here and then you
say oh this position where I'm two pawns
down the guy can't got me from doing it
this is deep this is ultra deep stop
right here this is not your casual oh
yeah the run-of-the-mill miss tactic
white I bet you if I give you this
position and say whites a move in win
how many players would find the rookie
for idea with Bishop e6 and then come to
the physicians seriously I would have
thought I would have something in the
double rook endgame right exactly would
we have found this if I'm playing an
opponent and he spins this out wand just
made a mistake which I'll know which I'm
surprised that in that an alert position
let's go to the actual game here after
rook takes they've gone right down the
hole
directly on the xe7 check why would he
allow this check first it doesn't seem
as though the the world is coming to an
end necessarily but why would he allow
this way first now white still has some
edge doesn't seem like it's a killer
though it seems like Richard Dahl is
playing with holy 47 seconds on his
colonic and Maxime has 56 minutes I'm
sure for sick I'm sure Maxime feels rich
tricks time pressure I mean it looks
like he's playing along with it he's but
at least now he stopped because
otherwise he would have taken
immediately on c7 this one is not
completely obvious that Grichuk is dead
but he's giving away a sleep on when he
didn't have to but I actually would have
thought this makes sense to me because
the C pawn is relatively worthless I'm
only aware the fact that this rooks in
the seventh but I'm gonna kick it out
yes a king g6 Brooksie for okay so this
is the moment where we had been
expecting
frankly rook hc8 and only after taking
the bishop do you take the knight he
started with taking the knight and this
God has all perplexed because he's
allowing a swishing zoo I don't why so
perplexing because King d6 you have to
play this is actually rather pretty you
don't see checkmate in the ending just
by accident the Ponte on h5 is covering
g6 but king d6 yes sorry go ahead
Alejandro take c4 Knight rook h e8 rook
on h8 - EA star crossing or pawn on e6
right yes perhaps I mean to me as a
human it doesn't seem that this end game
is worse than the other one
they both seemed like black should have
enough to hold but hold the C pawn
Maurice jump in with the game of fab'
well Gris Turk was in trouble in his
Russian compatriot Ayana napalm
Nietzsche who is currently tied for
first is also in trouble you know that
Yan plays very quickly right we know
that yan is a speedy customer he's
always picking putting the pressure on
his opponent well his couple of moves
Queen a3 and Queen 85 met properly by
Fabia especially with this move Queen t1
sent him into a deep spiral and guess
who only has 13 minutes left for the
rest of the game in a difficult position
he realized his problems here that he's
not getting the play that this diagonal
is a problem this diagnose a problem and
Danny D pawn is a problem as well he did
find what seemed to be the only defense
Bishop to d6 Fabi played correctly with
g3 no more mating ideas Kings are
perfectly safe and now King to f8 it's
time to be heating up with the king
bring the King out of that cage exactly
and now best move according to the
engine is Queen to d4 looks like it
makes a lot of sense centralizing the
Queen also threats potentially in the
position we Shaq made on h8 I chief
potential Bishop g4 all this is obvious
with a king or the g2 it's clear here
who has the advantage right no question
about it
yan is in big trouble will the
able to defend with limited time on his
clock and Fabiano pressing to try to
come back from his loss in round three
like it's ridiculous I mean and so many
players playing for first place I mean
at the same time right I mean by the way
King Lorenz game is kind of just fallen
off the wayside because the honest
England game is not about all the
content of the because EFA was played
Queen t4 was what Maurice is giving us
well King f8 like like he was saying you
just gotta escape the king side there's
a checkmate on g7 always looming so that
makes a lot of sense right and after
Queen D let's say after Queen hero
I'll keep I'll get on my Gideon that's
the thing I'm not really sure you can
play on EA because I think I can just
take your age 7 pawn and Queen it like
as simple as that
I don't know there's a perpetual here
with Queen and d1 h5 that I have to be
worried about so perhaps not that easy
that was what I was trying to set up
this kind of a triage of checks and it's
not easy and being told
yeah so but but there is Queen a8
however oh and that is a major problem
oh oh that came out of nowhere that's
like a billiard you're setting up for
this beautiful first of all you defend
the pawn on d5 you're setting up for
Queen c6 check and Bishop g5 and you're
right I'm just getting baited
I mean Queen b7 is also made goodness
sorry that means that King e8 is a no-go
you probably have to go to 7 and hope
that there's no bishop because I mean
you have to play the King out of FA
there's no other right yeah that's the
other but but aren't I walking into
something like this anyway I mean I'm I
think you have to go back to our fate
I'm not even kidding because if you go
to d7 half queen g4 and I don't see a
defense here you
okay once I probably look at five of you
be happy to go to d4 and now you're
really really yeah thank you that f-pawn
was at least keeping the seventh ring
blocked this is a real challenge that
lie above the line with Queenie for King
f8 oh it's 20 for King f8 oh wow so so
King well done what drew were you saying
King e8
Queenie for nothing I beg your pardon
because of Queen a8 because yes
Queenie for King f8 I know Bishop before
I'm not checkmate because Boyce is my
checkride the only move is coin b5 or a
little best move is Queen B are the e8
square against this Bishop g7 check
threat I'm shocked White's not winning
somehow White's doing really well you
could say that much why black is
completely tied down here you need to
move like a four feels like it's there I
don't know it but this is a tired
when fabbi entered this whole endgame
for a long long long time ago this was
his dream result oh yes you can't ask
for anything he's achieved as the
maximum we possibly could he's got his
pawn on h6 it's got his Bishop on d4
dominating has Queen in the center and
blacks Queen side pawns haven't moved
the pawn on d5 is the is the bomb I
think it's funny this position Bishop g7
shank yeah play King g8 live in that
hole that's a coffin
that is not nice guys this is an
absolute dream result for fabbi should
he win this game because that loss was
so crucial I mean it's not like the
tournament was over but if he beats his
number-one rival he's plus 2 he's got to
have him he's going into the free day
Fabi and he's played the greatest prep
ever ever and here we stand
after three rounds and we were just
saying Fabiano he's got that big fat
zero for that third round result give
that a one point result he's the guy
sitting at top at the leaderboard with
two and a half and it was just not to be
not to be dangler and came back awesome
boss let's go to it dear friend of ours
who has some chess insights as we have
the counts corner with Christian Corolla
[Music]
welcome everybody to the candidates
edition of the counts corner I will be
your host Grandmaster Christian korilla
and today I want to talk a little bit
about Fabiano Caruana strategy going
into this event he is one of the main
favorites and in my opinion he has
making he has been making the biggest
waves in the competition as of right now
in the first game against vascular Grove
after E 4 E 5 this in my opinion
potentially already a small surprise
because he has been playing c5 and going
into the trash Nicole after Knight to c6
but obviously this is a very dangerous
approach especially if your opponent
already knows that potentially you're
going to play this opening it's a very
dangerous opening I'm sure most of the
competitors have been analyzing this
during their training camps you know
that these players have been having very
thorough two months long training camps
in preparation for this tournament and
you want to surprise them as early as
possible and this is exactly what
Fabiano has been doing he played the
move e5 Knight to f3 of course Fabiano
has played there he Lopez plenty of
times where the white pieces with the
black pieces but after night we have six
Castle b5 Bishop to b3 Bishop to c5 this
is the first major surprise in my
opinion we haven't seen Fabiano played
Bishop c5 since 2014 that's six years
ago that's a long long time and this is
a very sharp variation because after a
four rook to b8 seat with d6 d4 Bishop
to b6 now white is faced with the first
big option you can take on b5 take on b5
and then go Knight to a3 but then you're
most likely going to have to after
Castle you're going to have to take on
b5 and after Bishop to g4 the position
gets very very complicated and you know
that with the new engines
potentially big big weapons could be
hidden
in this position and most likely Fabiano
have some amazing preparation in this
line as well of course
vassula graph was faced with a big
decision take on b5 going to the main
lines but risk heavily risk to fall
under fabiana's preparation and he
decided to go for a tamer approach he
played a move a5 which up to 87 h3
defending against Bishop to g4 Castle
Bishop to e3
he takes d4 C takes d4 but once again
Fabiano is pushing for the complications
Knight to before a very concrete move
Knight to c3 defending in pawn on e4
continuing attacking the pawn on e4
Knight to g5 Queen to e7 e 5d takes e5
and at this point already this is a
critical juncture in the game because
whites only good option is to go Knight
to f7 at this point Fabiano had one hour
and 40 minutes on the clock
while maxim had like 1 hour and 15
minutes on the clock
so big thing for maxim opening success
for Fabiano and we're going to see that
Fabiano has been having opening success
in pretty much every single game he has
played up to this point so let's go back
from the beginning this was round 1
let's see what happened in round 2 in
round 2 he was white against Carroll
alexengel and this was a big big game
because of course Kiril is the only
player that is just at that 2700
threshold is not like 2760 27 set 2760
just like every other player in this
competition 2800 he's nowhere close to
death he is around 2700 with the white
pieces you're going to want to score in
that game it's very very important that
you're going to try to score and Fabiano
Carolina plays the move d4 Knight to f6
c4 e6 Knight to c3 Bishop to b4 and f3
he never
laid this move in his life this was a
big shock
guaranteed for Alex Danko and a very
smart strategy for Fabiano because once
again heavily reliant on artificial
intelligence engines with Leela with
alpha zero you were going to be able to
analyze this position in completely new
ways and bring new ideas to the table
and this is exactly what Fabiano has
been doing I think f3 was a huge success
of course as we have seen in the game he
won quite easily with the white pieces
it completely demolished alexengel and I
think this f3 was an amazing amazing
decision for a team for the Anand in
round 3 of course that was the big key
matchup of the round and he played
against ding another huge surprise as
early as move to c6 it hasn't played
this move in a while in since 2017 night
of 3 Knight f6 Knight c3 take on c4 a
for Bishop to a5 and i25 East 6 f3 once
again a very sharp variation and this
was specifically aimed at ding-ding is
not a very versatile player he plays
mostly the same things he plays the
Catalan against against the Slav he
plays very very principled lines
he's a very principled players
especially in the opening and Fabiano
knew that he knew that he's going to be
able to target him specifically and
shift the game towards the waters where
he wants to take it and this is exactly
what happened Bishop to b4 right to c4
capsule King to f2 and once again an
amazing amazing novelty if I've
unfortunately for Fabiano it didn't work
out his way but once again he's posing
huge problems in the opening and very
very early on the first one in this one
was
move number two c6 coming with the Slav
showing his incredible preparation once
again and right now in round number four
he started off with d4 against the groom
felt nipple always plays place the groom
felt so I would assume this was a bit of
an easier approach to the game g6 Knight
to c3 d5 take on d5 f work wish up to be
Bishop to g7 Bishop to c4 c5 Knight to
e2 Knight to c6 Bishop to d3 a very
concrete and very principled option for
white you have the center and once again
we see the influence of the artificial
intelligence engines afterward to see
one night wave a5 Bishop to d3 Queen to
d7 we have seen this position in a
couple of games in that base but nobody
play the move age for this is definitely
a Lilla influence if I might say and
it's a great move and it poses some
severe some severe problems as white
you're not taking a lot of risks so I
like this approach against Nepal Knight
neppo is a very dynamic player he likes
his opponent to take risks in my opinion
this position doesn't yield as many
risks for white he has a pretty nice
game he's going to go age for age five
capture he has the center already
captured some more space on the Kings
side and just right to slowly slowly
suffocate blacks position I think this
was a very good choice once again for
Fabiano
so let's recapitulate what his strategy
is the key points he has a new style we
have seen that in game number two
against Alex Danko with that f3 names oh
that was just an amazing choice
completely unexpected
the second
the second key point is that he's
striking first in every single game so
far he has been striking first in the
opening that is huge psychological boost
and he's enjoying that for the moment
and of course new openings he's playing
new openings in almost every single game
and if they're not completely new he has
played them five six years ago and most
of these guys most likely have not
prepared against those because there's
so many ground to cover
and you're not going to be able to focus
on everything your opponent has played
throughout the career so he is very well
prepared and I still think even after
yesterday's defeat he is a big big
favorite to face Magnus Carlsen later in
the year so this was today's breakdown
these players strategy analysis
[Music]
[Music]
well we are back and thank you Christian
for those lessons also let's
insider-trading I was about on behalf of
all the other competitors in the
tournament except for Fabiano thank you
for explaining
Wow very very revealing beep and here is
the standing no result capture for in
this fourth round no that's far we are
still on a third out of play
covering up one time pressure for a lot
of people of course Christian but that
beginning of the game no results so far
three leaders still maxime beaugeois
graphic on a pony Archie let's take a
look at that Maxime game against
Christian because that is the thrilling
and game hasn't Maxime been able to put
pressure in the double rockin game
against Chris shirt well it sure feels
like it to me we left it just about
these parts we didn't see any
challenging of the rooks but a five was
on board very quickly came rugby one
check and was I think what a cunning
little check I know how sweet is that
right I'm not entirely sure root yeah
this is obviously chuckling but if I go
king of seven where is the actual when
is it there's no knockout here I I just
assumed there was I guess you want to
play rook eight seven
it's ugly but I do what I must yes
you're right I still have a path day
upon which I think will force you to
trade ropes like one day I mean h6
doesn't Wow okay yeah I was being
facetious there for some reason I didn't
see the the move look h7 he actually
played King II seven and we're up to
date we have to play here it also
challenges some real here for white
because I'm taking on e6 against any
rope Chuck right okay well let's it
let's imagine a rope check you are
taking on e6 did you see I think so okay
and let's say I'm taking this one with
the idea I'm gonna get my two connected
passers against your this is a difficult
situation for Christian do I give you
the two connected passers and run my
upon immediately or do I somehow try to
hold this one promise actually I don't
see how well I'm like gee
well maybe ricochet Brook he8 okay fair
enough
rook hg yeah okay don't be seven let me
toss in a check I just want to see where
the Kings gonna go I'm thinking that if
I can force you to go to f6
then I'll take on b7 and then there's
some checkmate right yes exactly
yeah I'll run the other way yes okay
fair enough you take and I'll go a four
right the question is do I have enough
counter play with your name on it's that
clear one is more deadly
Maurice jump right in here I mean this
is well what can we say about the Berlin
endgame it's double edged and it has
been double edged it shouldn't have
happened we understand because Maxime
should have won this game or at least be
pressing tremendously right now but I do
want to say something about double rock
endings I remember the late Emery Tate
who was a fantastic tactician and one of
the top african-american players was a
hero of ours in the community for many
many years it was an honor to be
mentioned in the same breath with that
guy when I finally got strong enough but
he remember watching him play game once
and he'd love to show off his games and
one of the games that he played he
allowed two rooks on the seventh and you
read in all the books you certainly read
in my system either like two rocks on
the seventh you can't let that happen
the game's gonna be over like not even
like you're going to calculate he's
gonna be over but he played he allowed
his opponent the ax to verse on the
seventh and then they just played a
normal position he said so rooks are not
doing anything on the seventh ranked him
nor you looked at it you said yeah
nothing's really happening and this was
more in the middle game situation but
even in end games that can be the case
and where did we see that we still that
recently in the game with Wang Hao who
was he playing as he was black
we're just sorting around three I
believe as a matter of fact it was
Bishop it was Grichuk himself Grizz
shook against Wang Hao where we the
rooks were appearing on the seventh but
when you looked at he you said but
they're not doing anything because two
rooks on the seventh by themselves
without something else going on usually
just isn't enough
it's just not enough you need more you
need a lot more well usually if you get
a little more like a pawn shows up on 86
and the King is frozen on the back rank
right that's a different thing because
one of the roots will get protected by
the pawn room the 6-2 rank maybe not age
six even g6 or f6 the point is if a root
gets protected you need more but if the
other guy has some stuff too like this a
pawn then it's a whole different ball of
wax so you look at a position like you
guys we're mentioning rook takes on g7
yeah you can get there but you're not
gonna curtail blacks movement you don't
have mating ideas now he can even ignore
you it turns out and give you this pawn
and then say alright let's play this
position and this one is just nothing
you take you take you can defend this
pawn he gets behind his own pawn it says
I've got something and the whole game is
different
so these rook endings are very deceptive
they look superior until you look at the
concrete factors in the position right
now it's all about this upon giving
counter play huge counter play for black
and unless white has a lot more not just
more but a lot more White's not going to
win this game before played in that game
defending that pawn on e6 putting the
group behind the poem but very quickly
Griffith simply put his rook from H to
d8 sorry I I was looking at some other
games sorry I played rugby one plate as
well so after rookie four I beg your
pardon just play catch-up with you here
for a moment
rook d7 checks on White's agenda came
rook hd8 yes yes one boy one yes and
that seems to be the current position
and I'm assuming I'm assuming them I'm
shadowing you if you the moment you play
I'm going to play rook a fade you go rip
the one I'm gonna shadow you so it has
been playing yes like a very concrete
ways to play by grace sure exactly and
again he's got his counter he's got his
cow that's in pretty George Maurice big
deal in the game with Fabiano Caruana
and the palm the Chi and Fabi has soft
played it instead of Queen d4 which
looks quite strong Queen F
re going in a slightly different
direction but neppo very quickly came
back with the forceful Queen e1 check
King to g2 and now the move f5 we were
worried about this move because this
Queen could double back to d4 and get in
the position but now neppo realizing
that because the queen is on f3 he's
restricted its movements and now with f5
he's gonna be able to move his queen out
of the way maybe go to e4 in some
position as king is a lot safer still a
precarious looking position but only of
this Queen can magically teleport itself
into the position doesn't look like
there's an easy way now there are some
concrete variances to calculate or at
least something to worry about this move
g4 looks like he could potentially could
be dangerous but again we've got this
Queen b1 move that's holding blacks
position together
apparently so a lot of the danger has
passed a lot of the danger has passed
now concretely that doesn't mean that
the game is over let's be real you can
evaluate it quietly here especially with
an engine running in vs. you actually
playing this sharp position your cell
clock to eating Yekaterinburg down to 10
minutes
with 7 moves to go so the actual reality
the evaluation of the position will say
blacks okay but I've got a thing for
Fabi this position after the move f5 if
you didn't see it coming
it's got to be trending uncomfortable a
little bit like I had a really good
position and it looked like I was gonna
do something and now it's not the same
anymore
we've seen this story before we've seen
the story from Fabi and I really I got
to say I'm uncomfortable because I've
seen him not do well in this kind of
situation if I do badly where things
start to trend poorly for him from a
good situation we just saw it in the
dealer end game so then he just goes and
he goes down we've seen this from him
before and this might be a moment for
him where he says okay okay okay
I get in let me just cool calm I mean
he's a fantastic player when you give
him a nice position for him to milk he
could play some fantastic amazing chess
we've seen him going seven game streets
when he's playing well he is a match of
anybody on the planet but sometimes this
superlative player could find himself
psychologically not quite there and not
make the best moves and the problem for
him is when he starts going the wrong
way and sometimes goes on tilt let's
hope for American fans that's not the
case right now but this position has
certainly transformed from the big
advantage that he had to one where now
he's gonna have to be a little bit
careful we'll get back out on that one
yeah so you have the game of Wang Hao
tournament leader against Kerala Alex
Sink on in that one
well I again it some of our perceptions
about the other positions may be
misleading I just wanted to go back a
move or two at this exact moment yes the
perception is really good for white I
mean if I can just get some things going
and I was a little bit surprised by this
decision to take right away he did I
think he's we've got another mover too
obviously five on the board attacking
the pawn on c5 have we seen b3 before no
I think well how is still thinking about
this one but it doesn't seem like he has
too many options well the problem as I
see it with c6 is like essentially this
pawn on b7 was a weakened weakness and
it's sort of like oh thank you so much
you've it's a big relief for black if he
can trade off that weakness I'm
anticipating instead the move b3 b4
simply defending this pawn on c5 and
eyeballing an opportunity to play week
night be 395 it feels to me like
weighing how as white is is on the sunny
side of it just come down to concrete
variations that's the problem
I played B 6 b6 so you're kind of like
challenge me me is this pawn cleaning or
no exactly so are you taking on before
it's
so I was going to see Brooksie walking
into Bishop basics but not bad Roxy a
bishop a 6-row takes e7 oh ok ok sorry
this is you you you are getting two
pawns for the exchange and a nice Bishop
I still feel I still four whites that
one pressing this yeah because the rook
is on this is so powerful yeah how do
you win okay that's different question
but I think I don't mean that position I
mean this position because you have to
get through CA right so you have to get
how do you get to how do you you're not
you need your night somehow I gotta get
my rook to b8 I gotta get my Bishop to
a6 you're not getting your work to be a
bishop d6 is gonna happen well and even
after again in all of those moves I
still know you're still I'm only gonna
yeah yeah yeah
okay so you need your knight to be part
of the game in order to make this
actually can I go like 84 that was the
move I was looking at the reason you
want to go E for is that this Knight
really wants to hop somewhere useful you
can't take with the bishop because if I
eliminate that one I'll be able to
promote yeah I don't have to take with
the pawn and then you can jump this way
and I am controlling this important
square right yeah and I don't feel so
unhappy that you've got double the e
pawns either well by the way that means
that b6 has been played so we might be
going through something very sharp so
this alright this is the position right
now on the board and we are anticipating
Maurice jump in speaking of sharp we did
see the move g4 appear on the board and
very quickly the move Queen to be won by
neppo all not afraid of any of these
endings Ponte she's gonna take back with
the Queen and boy he could just breathe
a sigh of relief all of the danger will
have passed probably quickly played a
move that does not appear with the
engines Bishop to d4 but doesn't look
bad and this one now it looks like
options for black no real threats
nothing that dangerous in the position
he could move his king away a couple of
squares even Queen c2 is a move Queenie
for a move
Queeny for vin works on it also does
work takes takes and not a real
advantage for white here either but
neppo decided why trade queens he
doesn't believe he's any in any danger
anymore king f7 a little bit closer to
this pawn sort of kinda cuz he can't go
diagonal but in this was i should here
he looks as though black knows the
danger is past now i just need to keep
playing good moves and let's see what
the guy does looks bobby has to be
careful I think just stay the course the
the advantage that the beautiful looking
initiative is gone don't mess this up
that's a remarkable if you could just go
back to that moment where fabbi played
the move Queen f3 how can it be that
you've got this nice comfy advantage and
a good-looking move i mean queen of
three not the worst move you've ever
seen in your life throws away the lion's
share of your vanity by the way Queen d4
looks so attractive exactly the only
thing is you you do have to know what's
gonna happen after this move because K
you are sending your queen away from the
action and this pawn is hanging there's
still this Queen check but I think it's
more this pawn than anything else if the
guy defends his position and you don't
have something concrete you might be
thinking what about my a pawn will they
take it and I think Fabi thought he had
to be a somehow concrete like he was
going to get into f6 somehow I don't
know what he was thinking
precisely but this idea with Queen d4
just looks so compelling that he had to
have had a concrete reason why he
decided he just couldn't play such a
good looking move well the problem as I
saw it is what you had said earlier
Alejandra which is you got to do what
you got to do and when you're black and
you see this move Queen f3 well from
Nepos point of view his heart skips a
beat and he gets to go oh I get to go
Queen e1 and f5 we should be restraining
the f3 Queen suddenly yeah and yeah I'm
right back in the game and he's thinking
happy thoughts suddenly for obviously he
had no time on his clock his position
was was bad and suddenly he's totally
fine totally fine it he's able to
exchange Queens whatever he wants
the move king f7 yes it doesn't is not
Queenie for a completely forcing but you
can't stop Queenie for you exactly 40:24
next move he'll play Queenie for next
movement that's good yeah that's a dead
draw exactly it's a and really there's
just no variations even to look at it or
I mean Queen e4 is gonna shut everything
down I just wanted to go back to the
dinger in-game sorry he's just getting
no love at all that's a I mean he's just
not played much of a game when we had
gone on our break I I did check maurices
engine it was going zero zero zero I'm
like the top three moves this game looks
like it's heading into a draw not a
happy camper I mean he's basically lost
one game and he's just drawn all of his
other games and this one too he's
blocked today though hard to press again
thing there and a very solid players
know what happens when you try to over
press with black I don't think it's
gonna be very upset about this one okay
fair enough
for ding glare and that will lead both
those players with the score of minus
one and just checking in on the grizzard
game let's just see what had happened
that was where Grichuk was rook was
shadowing the free rook on g5 and after
work takes g5 r g8 again this pawn kind
of march it's it's pretty fast well
let's see what what could he he do
possibly you oh okay we're threatening a
check and shadow I could also probably
start thinking of a3 at this point with
the rook even here you start thinking
that the third-ranked
it's fast it's true and Maurice well we
do have big news in that game which we
did expect in fact we are predicting a
draw in this position because Queenie 4
was in the plate after Queen to e3 takes
takes and now f3 truly deadening the
position do mean no chances here for
white to win black come be careful
trying to get these two against one
majority on this side going by
it looks as though this game should end
in a drawer Fabiano is certainly going
to be disappointed two games in a row
where he had promising chances only to
end up with maximum half a point out of
those two results to possibility two
possibilities he's got to be a little
bit dejected after this game he comes in
with this excellent preparation e again
you have that GM feeling that there's
something in the position once you have
the Queen on t1 the king is suddenly
going to f it doesn't feel natural you
feel there's something in this
positioning he wasn't able to find it
because normally he takes his position
he calculates it till the end
he places clumsy move Queen f3 which is
very unlike him because never and
sponsors Queen e1 at five your Queens
restricted and of the game right and I
think he just missed this idea
completely if you see Queen e1 at five
you can't go for this exactly and
conversely when you see Queen d4 posting
up and Queen eight plays itself it's
actually difficult to refuse Queen d4
yes it's such a natural move right it's
a fast move posting up in the center why
is that man who might be hanging but
really is this one ever gonna be taken I
mean so many threats yep on the other it
looks like checkmate yeah but we have
actually a real special actually
seriously folks we had a free day
Maurice put a lot of effort into this
special that's coming up Alejandra well
let's thicken with Maurice the
highlights of the 28th yes we're going
to go over the top five highlights from
the entire tournament trust me there was
so much left on the cutting board but we
had to pick five of them and this is
something Fabiana will want to remember
because of course it was the one that
allowed him to play against one Magnus
Carlsen we're gonna start with number
five the game between Vladimir Kramnik
big Vlad
say it ain't so that you're retired does
he produce so many amazing games and
this was just one of them from that
tournament in this position his queen is
under attack but he played the fabulous
night to e8
a discovered check on the king also the
night hitting the Queen Queen takes
Queen of course is impossible or he
doesn't
matter because rook takes only one move
and rook takes G eight would be a mate
that you don't see every day what a fun
position night to e a fantastic move by
Vlad and we go on to number four
Bobby had been doing quite well in the
event but he faced off against one of
his old nemesis Sergei car yakin and car
yak and I've been playing wonderfully in
this game and then in this moment he
found the monster blow bishop takes on
f7 hitting the Queen a discovery on the
rook these to pass pawns just too much
and he went on to dominate this game
throwing Bobby backwards but Bobby like
a champ came right back in around 13
with the tournament on the line and
playing against Aronian and it was this
position where he played the
scintillating rotates on its on h6 would
check forcing resignation as King takes
does not do anything after this check
you block and oh there's a nice
discovery hitting the King after King
back only moved Queens a so you can see
the position is completely collapsing
Bishop takes g6 would be monstrous and
force that force Aronian to resign but
probably wasn't out of the woods yet
because of the next game with my Madeira
by Madeira was playing against Alexander
Gris shook in this position in my
McGarrett was giving chase to Fabi and
this C pawn looks dangerous
let me Jeff said wait a minute I got an
idea let me take on b5 allow the pawn to
go forward let me take my own threat to
get a queen king blocks and just when
you see this pawn going he said what
he's gonna do he says go ahead you can
Queen I don't mind
pawn goes down to Queen you've got two
Queens but I've got a baby that's about
to Queen myself and your Kings are in
trouble do what you will this Bishop is
guarding the long diagonal the win came
right now as Chris Cook resigned and
this gave him only a half a point
deficit against probably going into the
last round but fabulous Fabi delivered
the goods in the last game a position
where he only needed a draw after
Madeira and Kuryakin drew there again
he said I'm not taking those thinking
draw let's play on and he got to this
position and this move doesn't look so
fabulous but it was they blew that
forced resignation he's about to win the
pawn it's not a superstar move but guess
what
it made Bobby the first American in
decades in fact since Bobby Fischer in
1972 to have a chance to play for the
undisputed World Championship title so a
big game for him and that is the recap
of Bobby's great 2018 and it was a great
2018 and here we're taking a look at the
number of appearances by the players
over the years who of these candidates
and there's only been formed that moved
in repeat players yeah alex under grid
strip definitely the most veteran out of
all of them having participated in in
2011 I believe those were the cousin
matches I'm mistaken right because it
was Gelfand - yes Magnus Magnus actually
lost to Levon Aronian in that match
because we have to look it up but there
you have it the veteran and by the way I
have to say that fabbi sure feels like a
veteran it's hard to believe he's only
put in two appearances because he seems
like he's not only easy number two but
he's been around so long as one of the
great second behind Corey Aachen that's
right 128 yep
very good okay where were we
well a great guys made move 40 so that's
that's good Joe I believe let's go to
Maurice and the game of chaotic psycho
yes it looks like he's channeling you
Alejandro c6 by Wang Hao and after
Bishop takes b4 you think you're just
okay nothing happening then the guy
plays efore and says knock knock wake up
as this move is now on the board the
point is you're trying to get that C 4
square for the night pawn takes can
actually be met by Knight takes on top
of it Wow f6 is hanging you cannot or
you don't dare capture that what you
could you could give up you
in this position for this bishop there's
a check just to make sure your King
steps away and then Bishop to e6 and it
will be count them five pawns against
three but you do have this rook that
could be problematic to that King is
this a winning position
I don't know this would be a lot of
technique ahead in this kind of position
I would think it seems very hard to see
how you actually pull this off those two
bishops even with this pawn gone but
then again with this pawn on and I'm
gonna defend it with a Bishop on c5 I
don't really see how white actually wins
this game exactly yeah those two bishops
those nice pawn structure put the bishop
on d4 anchor anchors aweigh very sharp
and the players don't have a lot of time
okay I'm looking at this correctly there
I move 29
well white just playing with 29 I like
Sankar with six minutes and a half left
and well how only with three they still
have you know 10 11 moves to make and
it's a sharp position I've taken on e4
with the pawn that's more or less what's
forcing right what happened is a pretty
stodgy stale affair but actually kind of
explosive I didn't want to play Knight
takes e4 I thought this kind of any
games this more or less charge out to
play Knight c4 let me control some
squares let me eliminate this Bishop I
want you to enjoy those two pawns Knight
takes e4 yeah to present I thought the
whole idea was 94 as well and it it's it
feels at least that careless is still on
the back foot he's gonna have to make
some good moves yeah hold the position
but let me let me attempt and just play
the obvious one for a moment so here I
really want to eliminate what is this
Bishop on that fire I think this Bishop
on a5 is just that's it that's it if I
eliminate this guy you're also thinking
if I eliminate your dark-squared bishop
I should be able to push something like
c7 bishop a six rupees heaven would be 8
it might take me a while but it might be
winning you slow but Sir sir can i play
93 in this position and there you take
this night Wow
not an easy one because if you take only
300 works then blacks holding and you
will be up some material out I think it
matters because your bone structure is
actually really bad right but are you
actually holding this because c7 is
going to come very quickly root B 7 B 8
and again you know it's a slow slow
maneuver I don't see the defense I see
your thermometer I just don't see the
defense right let's just see how
something like this might go where am I
putting my I don't need my pieces let's
just put it here you're looking at
Bishop a6 or rook b7 is I'm not sure cuz
right that's how you're gonna put a
bishop on C 8 and you're just gonna stay
there or I'm like yeah and then I'm
gonna bring my cam and then you're gonna
bring your oh thank you I like the way
you said that you're gonna do this I'm
gonna do that oh really okay I you're
right yeah of course I am
and then I that's that's holy yeah I do
see that Wow has taken on e4 so this
variations will be scrapped and he might
be going into the same game saying it's
a 2 result game let me see if there are
some chances in this one we were looking
at ourselves with something along these
lines where yes yes and yes you are
winning the exchange but look what
you've given up black will have five
pawns white will have three bonds and
whether it is by the way I can like
earlier I could have thrown in this
check and driven the King into the
corner and here's where I was kind of
like scratching my head saying WOW
blacks bishops posted up in the center
like this two pawns maybe I should have
played h5 by the way instead of Bishop
d4 no no rush to put my bishop on this
anchor square it's gonna be hard work to
win this I would say although like you
are saying I think the rook on the
seventh rank just does make a very
pleasing impression yes but white white
is not risking anything that's
sure if the black King were on some
square let's say d6 yeah we would I
would start to get a little bit worried
if I was white so just keep that in mind
but it does feel like a to result game
checking in once again on the game of
fab' the moment we saw the move 5-3 this
is where we gave it up it looks like a
draw
okay just many many many many ways this
can be a finish to the draw just double
checking in on that and then the grip no
Christian handshake imminent rook takes
if you can vertex Jade is absolutely
forced in this position after h6 and I
think h6 is just an offer of peace yes
take on f6 carving of the point yes it
seems absolutely forced to me right yeah
take on g8 you take on a4 and this looks
absolutely that right whether it be with
h5 or even kingdom c6 an eventful game
and boy we leave some season and an
amazing decisive victories but what a
miss miss that was a big miss by oh
we're looking exactly at this exact
moment this is where this beautiful
exchange sacrifice it kind it comes out
of nowhere but once you see it on the
board you you put it on the board then
it becomes incredibly obvious yeah the
near coordination is just so strong and
your opponent's not doesn't have a plan
you have so many pawns going forward
once you see it it's obvious yeah but
that exchange two pawns to begin with
bit shocked he didn't find it yes so
much time yeah and it's so much time to
see and it's the type of calculation
that we've come to really appreciate
from specifically this yeah I understand
it there were a lot of hidden variations
that were difficult specially rookie for
Bishop e6
right let's just go back to that because
this is another one that we kind of
would have expect this is the hidden
check because the more hidden one you
but he uses this position I start
thinking does to move five four but
how's he figure root G five doesn't work
because I think that's what I'm drawn to
first yes your your rook is on pre you
get your rook out of pre and by the way
don't forget your nice hanging this is
what I would be an attractive to I think
the reason is that maybe Knight c3 still
holds because ninety-five Bishop III
looks a bit disastrous yeah you don't
want to walk into that monster pin but
Knight c3 on the other hand you said you
don't don't be touching the pawn on g7
because at the moment your rook is
hanging and you could end up hanging
both so your rook would have to move and
well if you move rook moves here there's
this but once you get past yeah rook g5
and then you actually look at Bishop
check and this is the real tough one I'm
sorry but but for me you you and at this
point you might have stopped I mean
you're the adrenaline is running
everything is and you go holy smokes I'm
two pawns down I know I can't play like
this I mean my opponents ready to play a
five a four I would be no I'm winning
I'm not losing my rook is going to f7
then it's going to go to e7 check I'm
gonna double on the seventh it's
completely winning yeah it's a beautiful
it's a very judgment
it's a tough judgment to make from afar
right I mean we'll have it the position
in front of us and of course and also
helped us but if you see this from a
fart you're not so convinced this is
winning it's two pawns it is too far
there's a pass to a pawn right so
perhaps something like this was what
Maxime saw waited and evaluated properly
we'll certainly I tried hearing you it's
easy to give up on a on a variation I
don't think we saw this position you
know I don't think he saw this position
that we're talking about you're talking
about we're looking for rookie four
right here ecigs yeah a four where are
mine a four here we go so this you have
to see this
yeah right and and then you see this in
this and
right here I think the most plausible
explanation is what you said on the
hydro that in this position what do you
look for tempo moves right right you
look for a tempo moves you're in a
forcing variation so you're gonna look
for tempo most so the move that's after
you look at Bishop g5 he plays King e8
you could easily stop right there
because route g5 you look at that you
realize the knight gets in the game
he's hitting your rook he's threatening
90 to check you can't make any moves
like this rook takes it goes of King f8
the suddenly he's back in business it's
nice coming back all right but if you
decide rogue g5 doesn't work where are
you supposed to do your Bishop check
looks like it's just a move and now you
have no forcing moves you play chess in
combinative style you've sacrificed now
it's time for the forcing move and you
look at the position you say yeah you
know he's King doesn't look that great
rook here
you might even ghost a move like this
trading rooks forgetting that you're
even attacking the knight but also the
knight gets a tempo on you're coming
back in the game already you're I can
just see his brain says just not even
getting here and then if we got this
quickly was like no this doesn't look
right this is not how it works right
instead to go further and find this and
then evaluate the guy's got moves and he
just can't do anything this is an
incredible thing to find results on the
boards show Dingley rent has drawn
against a nice giri and maxima sherrilyn
graph has drawn against Alexandra Chris
Chuck so to having of the points already
and yet had I'm very quickly in the MBL
game as they played the king versus king
the King versus King just as spectators
after age 6 this is where we pretty much
given up as a drone just to repeat
everybody should know of course no draw
offers before move 40 which means they
could off at this point but I offered a
draw but they've quickly they got to do
what was coming and we got King and
versus King on the other hand a draw was
offered in the contest
that's really needed Oh was it okay well
that makes it simple yeah for the roofs
42 Kings or five big was the dgt enabled
now also I just want to go back to what
Maurice was saying again about oh sorry
now now I'm more confused because of
what Maurice was saying about this whole
sacrifice because I like what everything
that was being said right up to this
moment
pardon me right here so we were looking
at rookie four yes Bishop e6 I take and
just as you were saying alejandra look
for those tempo moves and I love this
move
yeah and then comes this move and I love
this move and I easily calculate this
because everything forcing I can
calculate now I'm thinking that I should
just move my rook
take my rook and I've got two connected
pass pawns
your rooks are on aged eight and eight
and I'm like they're just looking at h6g
v g6 that's totally winning me if you
want to play
that's why h6 chief yeah as totally
winning and so like now I start to think
well for sure Maxine would have seen
rook g5 because that's the tempo move
for sure he would have seen Knight c3
hitting the rook for sure he would have
seen you look hitting the night so he
evaluates rook g7 King f8 as bad for him
or something is so that's let's continue
rook d7 right Knight takes III Bishop
takes c3 right and now let's see I mean
I could just push my pawn 85 it you know
past bones have to be pushed it exactly
I'll do my the same I don't see who wins
the race a 3G remember I do have whoa my
the computer really didn't like the move
I just place I thought I was pushing my
past bonds you just told me past bonds
but push him baby yeah but I guess
they're not really going anywhere
well our ninth right and apply G so you
can play King g8 maybe okay so
what happens if he pushes a - is it okay
- well it is probably just a draw right
she summons and I can defend with Bishop
T for Italy I've always got Bishop D for
right mm-hmm but maybe that's not a win
for sure okay well I actually was
playing from the perspective that I
thought that might pass pawns would mean
that my rook and Bishop would be winning
but I guess that's not all so in that
line by the way without playing a five
this is very cheeky move bringing the
pawn back stop take on e3 right here the
very cheeky King g8 with rook h7 coming
and now you're gonna set up on the light
squares now yeah that's a nice
completely miss beautiful annoying white
I'm just gonna be blocking you in the
lights no this is terrible party poopers
that's what you guys are who draws can I
just take a look at our standings after
those two yeah they're in the history
books and we have a leader for the time
being Maxima share that graph excuse a
result of two and a half out of four a
plus one we do expect him to be joined
by yonder pony actually as that game
seems to be really dead wrong because
Xavier karana
and young one house should also join him
in two and a half because well the edges
are giving white a plus but in my
understanding of chess is this a game is
a dead draw exactly against Kerala Alex
& Co so we expect no big no changes at
all in the standings coming into round 4
leaving around for us we do I think it's
gonna be four draws for today which will
be a first
we have been faded with some amazingly
amazing number of decisive games good
some good games today a real miss and
I'm looking at the game
Carroll and Wayne how and I'm forcibly
reminded of a story that Gary Kasparov
told me he was playing in the Spartak
Iyad these were the internal Soviet
republic Olympiads you know each
Republic of the Soviet Union would send
a team and they had their Spartak yet
and he Gary Kasparov hanniger in
position where he had a bishop and upon
versus in exchange and he was trying to
make a draw and he called Michael bought
Vinick in Moscow and he said you know I
got the situation and he'd he hadn't
even put the position on the board yeah
and Bob vinick's said is your bishop
protected does it have an anchor square
and gary said no he said you were lost
yeah and it was just like so revealing
it was like like and Gary just like was
just done by this understanding and here
you can see that black has two pawns
yes and an anchor square for the bishop
yeah dad draw nothing to discuss very
very very easy draw for the black side
the bishop is is powerfully protected
and it's been agree to draw one has
drawn against Kirilenko so we're really
only waiting for the result of Fabiano
karana and Yana Pagliacci and that looks
even more drawn than the other game
right now we were just thinking who
who's the one presently or thinking
about their chances is is it does black
have any ideas does neppo have any ideas
of a six b5 on a good day he can trade
off the b-pawn for the deep on the
second no not that maybe I come rushing
over thinking and isn't that pawn on
aged six weeks now so you're not
convincing anybody this is this one I'm
ready to give you five to one are just
like 50 to one
okay I'll give you seven to one I'm
gonna be as long as your one is a
hundred bucks about ready to reach for a
Lincoln and then he's said a Benji I'm
not sure this will be the round of
missed opportunities brilliant missed
opportunities for sure this this game
man back here when he had this chance he
got the he had a chance to play Queen do
you won the first time right he played
crazy
alright no problem you know no problem
better the second time and you get to
play the move and now the position just
looks so sweet the guy goes into a big
thing you get to get everything right
with the world now it's time to
centralize the Queen you know ninety
percent okay maybe it's not ninety
percent but the majority of chess
players I would say eighteen hundred on
up and even those lower than that would
be like don't insult us we would apply
Queen D for who doesn't play Queen D for
in this position is that well the number
two player on the planet looked at it
and said it's not enough I don't like it
I'm not gonna go for it and said he play
this move Queen f3 and instantly this
Queen left into the game and if five
showed up on the board
imagine if your queen we're here no f5
for sure but no it's here curtailed in
its powers and he missed this chance
Maxie misses chance as well so I think
those two players will go back Mike
seaman he I don't think he saw it well
we know he didn't see it we know he
might have been analyzing the variation
so I don't know which move in that line
that sequence he didn't see but you know
somebody said there's always one it's
always who's gonna be the first you
missed the move and for Mac seems to go
Wow mm that would have been a good
chance to go +2 and take over soul lead
in the tournament Wow let's see how he
handles that
he's still only tied but guess what he
is still type of person after three
results here it is a tie for first
between MBL and wang hao as they're
sitting at two and a half expecting to
be caught by Yann Neff Oh also with one
game pending I just want to go back to
this game by MDL because it makes it a
very powerful impression right here at
this moment because I for one was
questioning his pawn sacrifice he played
the move Bishop c1 Knight takes Knight
back and already right here he's
purposely sacrificed this pawn for
incredible play yeah exactly so he knows
what kind of compensation he was looking
to achieve once he gets here I mean he's
eyeballing e6 f7 yeah all of these moves
so many tactics of the position exactly
and then this move by the way very very
nice restraining move rook f5 and this
move and so he's really been playing for
this fantastic long-term compensation
and then suddenly he comes up with a
second pawn sacrifice so then it becomes
really hard to understand where his
misses were because he he's played for
this compensation for this combination
move the entire game and it's like the
logical follow up he's not if I
sacrifice you're doing strong things
against your opponent's pieces and then
suddenly it's like yeah just yeah this
is that crucial moment right here but
Bishop e3 seems very forceful it seems
very natural
you played a four you said a the other
who say B I think frankly if I could by
the way they're still playing this game
and I'm I'm ready to give you a 10 to 1
year decisive result whenever you're
ready not whenever you're wrong
whenever you're ready card it no way in
the world no I'm having you do that so
this this is what we had look when he
played a four back here yep
the point was to play Bishop III that
was the point he saw the line he said if
you take my pawn play Bishop a3 I play
easy exactly what happened in the game
you must play c5 I play six you put up
sticks and I'm crashing through I'm
crashing through that's his narrative
I'm crashing through with this
opportunity I got a pawn on e6 you're
taking this I'm taking this off
something's dropping here I'm getting on
the seventh I'm rolling maybe he was
blissfully unaware maybe he never even
thought of working Ricky for the guy
defends okay whatever
Bishop 83 is what he wanted to do and
that's that momentum that inertia just
took him in the direction of his
calculation that's why he played a four
I mean to me that seems like the real
story in the position that like that's
probably what happened he played a force
he could play Bishop 83 and he saw this
line and he thought it was good for him
maybe anything was winning but to think
that I am not actually winning the game
with rookie four and all those come and
by the way the bishop doesn't ever go to
a3 the bishop man is about g5 of all
things I don't think that's the
narrative I think we you know very easy
and you buy the the engine showing us
you know this path right because then it
looks easier than it actually was his
narrative his mindset was a for Bishop
a3 that's what I think and I'm seeing it
as like you suckered the guy you got the
guy to put his bishop on a four you got
him to put his knight on a four so that
the pieces are discombobulated on the on
the fourth rank you get to play rookie
for trapping the bishop to the knight
the bishop can move except for that
Bishop e6 variation and then you
sacrifice and that's when you realize
you know like the beauty of your play
look everything is logically brought
together it came together so nicely
right a big mess another bigness for
fabbi let's just take a let's bring up
the fabian because that's the one game
going unfortunately for you guys I am
I just want to please I just want to see
the look the position we have right now
but if I was shaking forever which means
er this is something he's sake that
it'll like something is lurking
something's lurking King Defour loses by
the way what came before and lose it
straight up because b5 is winning so you
got to be a little bit careful well
somehow my the the chess ammeter I
thought if you take on b5 and I go there
should be six I was being so tricky and
this opponent game certainly must be
losing totally well this was the dream
what I was saying is you can use the
b-pawn as a decoy you get to get this
pawn so there's king after d5 there's a
little trick after b5 it really must be
a joke right I thought the King before
was losing because of b5 now the after
little with your assessment there yeah
so there is a trap in the position there
is a trap on the position right that's
wondering what is White's move in this
position okay so I just okay I'll play
naive right naive it might be the
correct way of playing just ask you are
you going to somehow try to play a
bishop on d6 put the ship on FA say
maybe I have some kind of zoos wrong
because one day your folks ball I don't
know a buffet why are you putting a
visual on e3 yes kind of things do you
go King e5 and then I go b4 now we now
we calculate and you're going here I'm
definitely faster because h6 is hanging
exactly oops
yeah and you get to play b2 as well I
know I disagree what I'm doing sorry
Maurice I don't understand why you you
want me to put the bishop in in just
watch play the rest of the game maybe
you have to be careful oh there's a guy
serving every time
kingi how do we evaluate that well
you're losing yes well guys waving his
hand over there so okay yeah you keep
the bishop on before you defend with
Bishop g7 that looks much nicer right
okay nothing to see here
well but again Bobby's thinking which
usually it's an indication of some point
we're not going right why don't I have
any time on Abby's clock I I think he
flagged right now and he hasn't been
added his 15 minutes so as soon as he
makes a move you'll see the extra time
on his clock so he had so just to be
clear he has not lost a game thank you
that was what I wanted to hear the
reassurance kind of hard to do it's move
41 that just got played yeah so Fabi
would have had to lose after Bishop e3
yes no but he did not ain't good
actually you have to lose after 84 move
40 a 4 so he would have had to play a 4
with no time on us right that would have
to be in the fly but now that he's
actually played 41 Bishop e3 Ryan said
he certainly is well into his own time
because it's the time control is 40 at
the 40th move so you have to lose on the
40th not the 41st and yeah this is a
little tricky but Bishop on d4 should
get the job done and both of them will
have passed pawns but nothing to do with
him mm-hmm
but I got to feel like Bobby's mine
isn't quite right you know one of those
things you'll see happen often it's the
illusion of opening prep you feel like
if you're prepped from a theoretical
standpoint that that should give you the
advantage in the game I feel really well
preparing the confidence when you see
your prep not pan out it's I said this
at the beginning of the tournament it's
really going to come down to form all
right more than anything else it's gonna
be your confidence in your form right
you you have to be you just have to be
ready to play chess your openings I'll
give you their openings look what
happened to to a nice giri against Neff
yeah great prep you played fast good but
who was plenty with power in that game
great defense nepo and then he turned it
around and then pure endgame technique
who was playing all the prep of the game
with ding Lauren Fabi was all that great
prep but eight six what kind of move is
that showing lack of confidence this
game again great prep lead where you can
get your opening preparation
congratulations but if you're not
playing great chess after that you're
not fooling anybody you're not just
knocking these guys out there are too
good their defensive skills are going to
be great it's what you bring to the
table after your prep that's going to
make you the chance here and that's what
we're seeing he's not in fantastic they
we called it again
fabulous form and it's showing it's
really showing I notice he gets it
together he's not gonna be the one who
challenges Magnus Carlsen for the world
crown thank you for that I mean one of
the things that really has stood out
especially in those first three rounds
was defense I mean in the I remember so
many games of Gary Kasparov career so
strangely enough before he became world
champion I mean he became the number one
player in the world and he was just
destroying people with prep yes I mean
guys were just falling off dying they
were not putting up the kind of
resistance that we were seeing in this
tournament that there's the play the
defense of skills of the players is just
yeah the tactic levels for a lot of top
top level players it's still there some
tactics you can see aggressiveness
calculating technical skills the
difference between defense now yes and
defense then it's night and day right
workable even some in case we now
considered to be basic they have to be
figured out a lot of this Fischer end
games were you know for us it's obvious
you know for example the Bishop and pawn
and game you know you have to go behind
the pawn not on the side it's like
that's obvious to me because I grew up
with it but it back then it was such a
revelation a lot of Defense's and
openings where you know that if you take
a pawn you're just gonna grab the pawn
you're going to defend yeah it looks
ugly for a while but guess what it's
apollomon
you can just defend it people were just
falling apart they would take the fun
and just get made it exactly just a
different type of Cheston you were
mentioning it yeah big difference sorry
to say we had hoped to bring you an
interview with Tingler in you know how
it is over there in Russia these days
everybody's taking extra extra extra
precautions so we couldn't bring you and
in really hope to have set up
everybody's anxious to ask him about his
games with happy but okay yeah I mean so
the situation is quite uncomfortable
people are diffusing going out for walks
they're not in socializing pretty much
at all I mean it's not just practicing
social distancing this is quarantine
you know we but you couldn't understand
that from the organizers point of view
they don't want any player to come down
with co19
right so that'll be the end of the term
that would it be it yes and so they are
taking those triple precautionary
measures sometimes we joke that you're
kind of Anna quarantine when you're in a
chess tournament you go Cheney then talk
to your second and that's it right but
it's actually pretty uncomfortable for
them a lot of these players like to go
out and wash they like sure you know
meet up with the other players got some
dinner maybe some of the other seconds
of their friends with a lot of the
seconds are missing a lot of the players
are not allowing their second so you can
go out to the city and you can see
anything right there you go that's
already tough right
I mean chess tournaments are tough on
their own and having such a restrictive
routine is surely going to take a toll
on a lot of these players down the road
I mean we're only talking about four
rounds of chess so far out of 14 and of
course they have to think in terms of
this event
you know lockdowns are happening around
the world they ever get to go home you
know for example fabi's family is in
Madrid which is complete and total
lockdown right now you get fine for
being on the streets even yeah so it's a
tough situation all around and we'll see
which players can cope with it better
than others yeah different girl
difficult challenges indeed
well should we just be taking a quick
break I'll say guys you know what
you look at a position like this and you
see somebody of the class of a Fabiana
Caruana and he's still making moves you
got to imagine that he does see some
danger here and you know I felt like
yeah this is just a draw it should be a
problem but looking at this position
after Bishop to d2 right there could be
some some things for you to worry about
he did like King d4 here
what was the 10 sorry you actually
played b5 here but take a look at this
the engine gives this as still equal
still equal right still equal you're
still doing all right
so I said okay what this King be service
on the by the way very very cheeky move
I said well what if I just wait and then
agent says you're dead whoa just now
you're giving away a piece well now
maybe maybe the game's not obvious over
over but you do have to be mindful of
the opportunity for black to play King
b6 okay play for B for play King a5 and
roll down the board gotcha yeah okay of
course so that is something that fabi's
star in the field maybe that's hiding in
the position and he needs to be careful
beyond the watch for this particular
plan so right now
yan is definitely playing well I can't
say definitely but it's yarn who's the
one who knows he has an advantage he's
got this part on this side he's got the
outside passed pawn and he's maybe I
won't win the game but let me give it a
punt let's see what happens so what is
the correct defense instead of this move
Bishop d2 worries
instead of Bishop to d2 moves like
Bishop f6 apparently get the job done
King b6 now can be met by check sorry
you're not coming in being a that
quickly there's no King a5 happening so
the bishop just has to stay on the right
diagonal and wait him out
after first time oh you just can move
the King right bishop da King a6 yeah
you check King to a6 and then you can
wait ah because as long as you wait on
d3 before it can be amended to King c4
yes yes ready to go right to the square
so this move so the point is to keep the
black King out of either a 5 or B 5 from
entering into the game that's going to
be the key
and we expect that's what fabi's being
careful for now so the game actually is
in if I can get things it does seem like
black and just force that draw something
like so this is the position point yeah
Bishop d6 can be pledged easily but I
guess black knows he's not gonna lose
the only thread in the position is this
D pawn and that's double blockaded so
that's not a worry can t somehow make
the b-pawn into something active as a
way for black to lose this game yeah
your King goes behind it and your bishop
is supporting it well suddenly the deep
on it's not protected by that man that's
true that's true yes to be mindful yeah
he starts playing for a win he does have
to make sure that for example one of the
kings on a6 I start to worry if I can
challenge to Bishop on d6 am i fast
enough in the opponent game yeah those
kind of things I think he definitely
wants to calculate which is why she
probably will take a little bit of time
to figure out his next move very good
well we're gonna sneak in a very quick
break here as we continue our live
coverage of the 20/20 candidates match
round four as we have one game remaining
after three have already been agreed
draw yeah we'll be right back
[Music]
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen be surprised
be intrigued be delighted the world
chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015
SLU partner with the st. Louis chest
look to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
Peace inception slough obtained second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University can you hear it it's the
sound of hope and health
and strength it's the sound of
compassion of open doors where people
and machines are in tune and miracles
occur
it's the sound of personalized health
care and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back it is round four of the
candidates and these are the current
standings after three results already in
today's rounds three draws as Maxine
Bashara graph and one how cling on to
their top position we expect they will
be joined by Jana pony actually as the
fourth draw of the day but of course the
players are still fighting it out on
this one between Fabi and the Russian
chess player so since our break since I
raves nothing has happened we still
expect that to end in some sort of draw
but if anybody's got the chance
it's definitely onion side of the day
yeah he does have this pawn on b5 as
Maurice mentioned going into break this
pawn on d5 sufficiently blockaded on a
really really good day black soul
winning idea would be to play b5 III to
give up this pawn in return to get his
King on d5 there will be let's say a
white King on b3 and then he's got some
chances the problem is he can't
effectuate that exchange we were looking
at black trying to oh let's make a move
for a white for a second we were looking
at black trying to bring his King over
to the Queen side to try to penetrate
through a five and a four we this could
be met yes by the bishop on d8 and fabbi
could hold a draw that way is that the
best way for him to do it Maurice that's
not necessarily because check this out
okay while I was thinking about this
position and I know it's supposed to be
a draw but you gotta at least think
about it
so what is Fabi think what is neppo
what's taking him so long right now
because the move Bishop d6 seems called
for well Bishop d6 does have a straight
flaw it gives up this diagonal which is
the key diagonal that black once right
black wants to bring his King over so I
said well what if you put your Bishop on
a5 which seems counterintuitive the
engines don't mention it at all but when
I play Bishop a5 they go yeah that's
drawn to no big deal because that's the
diagonal you want you can bring the king
or if you want I already have the
diagonal we finally have a move it
should be six and he's decided not to
concede the diagonal he plays Bishop to
b6 the point is you can't get anything
going here because if you try Bishop f8
he's just going to play Bishop d2 you
play King c7 oops the King comes in and
now your King has to go back to d7 and
you have you you can't get any progress
because just gonna come back so that
doesn't work
so Bishop a5 and if you try to get on
this side well watch out now because if
you go strain too far then there is that
deep on that you will have to worry
about in this line and this D pawn
becomes dangerous itself so this is
another plan this Bishop a5 plan very
solid plan indeed that shows that there
are a multiplicity of ways to win this
position and Bishop your 60 instead of
playing this there should be section I
guess I should say grammatically there
is a multiplicity of ways so in the
position but Bishop e6 check played
looks like he can play anything King e5
King 14 king d3 the engines give and say
you got nothing there's no way to go
here well so maybe you might see a
repetition with this move maybe maybe
this well hooking f6 right
oh yeah man I was trying to hit that
repetition so we could go home King goes
you could self mate if you wanted to you
know some kind of king up and pawn push
maybe five mate not gonna happen okay
okay so this is a draw so everything is
wrong mr. B six check played I I think
King e5 yeah I don't see what's with the
suggestion of king f6 I think the only
thing you have to be careful is that
Bishop c5 before b3 doesn't when you're
a bishop but it does feel like at this
point blacks also risking are you gonna
play this way yeah yes
and then after King we're gonna go key
eight King oh you wanna do you wanna do
this to try every temple sorry oh of
course
so being say let's toss in b3 agreed
because you got to play Bishop right
that's fine and then now I actually do
have because I don't think I have
chopper tunity as black to play Bishop
III and play the move b2 and just that
would be very nice I'll be 53 Bishop
here and now I give the pawn push give
that guy is give this guy everybody in
yeah only one person could win but hold
on with the King going back to EA can
White's King find itself trapped like so
so I'm sorry this is ook so long maybe
like King takes h7 king of seven I know
I am assuming that Bishop a3 is some
sort of threat it's a but easy to stop
and Isis on your leg Bishop d6 say
Bishop FA Allah Misha pave that like
hitting the h6 pawn just take King on h8
out of the equation to play Bishop d6
because not able to get a nice dragon
although I'm sorry I know I need to play
b-26 is what I wanted to play go and do
this one yeah sure that I'm bishop see
what I have Bishop e5 how do you zoom if
he's gonna always move this Bishop f4
okay no but okay now I think what I
think at that point even h7 you're not
meeting me on the Dagon and as soon as
you trade bishops King g8 will be just a
drop
okay seven per second just was this
[Laughter]
normally within the move g5 yeah and you
are stone cold looks long you can't move
the big hammer your bishop because the
visual go to c1
you got a five main can't push you'll
take it and yeah that's no reason saying
itself mate not necessary it is all
about King H came back to h7 though yes
go back in the border right you can look
song white but white has too many ideas
why does his D pawn wise blockading when
King h8 looks like he has too many moves
but one of the things that stands out
about
these variations it's why it's because
if I see those variations I think well I
ought to be fair king e5 Bishop c7 with
the cooking of sex you can yeah you
gonna move yet but king e5 was the move
looks cooler
King e5 almost forces blacks hand if
white is fine rushing into the position
and going after the H pond then the
black really has no chance but the thing
is if you're Carolina you got to make
sure because you know right you guys
were all you guys are both going maybe I
got a little tricks to thing here man
look here yeah it's a could be a
trapdoor variation you better make sure
you see all the possibilities when you
go here and that's not that easy to
calculate right so that's gonna be the
trick for him to be super confident that
he can go this path get his king frozen
and then there's nose looks long if he
realizes that then no problem but that
is not simple realization
that's calculation and that's where Fabi
he's gonna be sitting on this position
right now and might just play the safe
move which by the way safe moves also
juror right but you might not go for the
most forcing line it's by King t3 and
there you go you go that line is so
forcing he said let me back away and
keep my keep keep that you know me on
the safe side of the bed mhm
right did you see why go down the line
where they maybe his look somewhere and
I don't see it right now he stays on the
safe side of it and he's still fine so
the safe side being that after king d6
stepping up and attacking the pawn king
e4 and I can't squeeze my king through
on the Queen side because I'm actually
right walking into a skier or even those
positions where you do go with king c4
latina I give you that move for free
they're not that clear right tell me
which is like if you played in one move
King c4 right now because you want to
we're gonna cheat white for a second
right
we're gonna allow sorry I just forgive
me for what I'm doing I'm trying to get
the transitions yeah we're somehow we
cheated and we've let blacks King
squeeze through right and this is all
very tempo dependent right understood
but even in that case if it was right
and this is the best case best case
scenario everything this was white team
um I think white is actually winning
winning winning yeah I think so
Wow these teacher just go t6 and I think
you're faster d6
well yeah yeah yeah it's it you cheated
sorry I was trying to get at somehow a
tempo so you're saying that I cheated
and and if I had gotten this position is
achieved his best which was to get his
King through the Queen side and you're
saying I feel like black wasn't some
danger but because I'm not no I don't
think you can take directly God you just
wait a second like before king e5 and oh
I'm sorry you're stepping back with that
thinking can you have six King g7 and
I'll take on h7 your king is too far
away to really contain mine maybe it's
maybe that's still the draw you still go
back in time yeah here I have cycling t7
so I'll be I'll be good I couldn't even
take on e3 and 57 probably that's
winning also yeah so it's not so clear
that getting the King to c4 is actually
going to be a huge progress for black
not to mention weekend Wow okay so we're
just looking at variations that might be
even on a good day and he's playing the
move Bishop to c5 which controls the a3f
a diagonal that prevents white from
establishing his own bishop on that one
okay but we had mentioned a moment ago
that maybe it was important to stop
Bishop a5 as establishing the draw okay
but Bishop c5 basically says three
immediately play against immediately
region
immediately and jumping right is there
pretty dead okay
I think once the bishop gets to have six
in it yeah we were talking about if you
ever go Bishop FA b7 it's a nice retort
yeah that's that's attractive so Bishop
c3 on the board I don't see anything
mm-hmm no that that certainly appears to
be the case any other Tricky's left that
you can see them yeah I know
playing challenge magnets car wow man
you're so vain they think we're actually
watching them right I I think they're
trying to see what they could do resting
our patient it's it's looks like it's uh
it's gonna be a job yeah and if you're
enjoying this don't worry there's plenty
of chess laughs we actually have have
very exciting day sitting today's well I
mean we were created fantastic yeah
those first three rounds and again what
a game between Fabian ding but as we're
seeing scheduled tomorrow we'll have
around 5 then on Monday we'll have down
6 a break date on Tuesday and then again
three games and a rest day three games
in a rest day and then the last two with
the incredibly unlikely scenario of
playoffs on April 4th if that were to be
the case okay since we have a little
time tell us why it's incredibly
unlikely to be a playoff because the
first I break is head-to-head that could
easily be so for example if ding Larian
and Fabiano or didn't tie for first for
first and considering the Fabiano
doesn't beat him in the second at all if
they draw or Tingler and once again and
they're the ones tied at the end and
England would be the challenge
four against magnus carlsen because that
is the first tiebreaker
this the head-to-head match illusion
makes fear for good sense yes
now imagine that fabbi does in the
second half big deal and they both still
tie for first but now they're equal when
their heads up what's the second the
second fabric will be amount of
victories so amount of decisive results
what Nigel short likes to say the amount
of losses better your tie break that so
decisive gear size against currently of
course Tingler Anna's leading in that
category Oh in this case you have
somebody like Grisham also defeated
terrible tie Rick because he gets plus
one plus two
yeah but he's not ahead of anybody
because o plus three he can't winning
the tournament okay yes but who is
winning the tournament okay so the
second criteria is number of decisive
games yes then the third criteria is a
mathematical tie break that I don't want
to go formally you can look it up if
you're really that interested it doesn't
usually go all the way there right but
by that point it's usually stopped I
mean really beating this mathematical
library the mathematical formula that
determined madness because it wasn't
their head-to-head and I don't think it
was the decisive game maybe I think I
think I think - had one more decisive
game than Kramden that was from what I
remember that was the 2013 yes 5 wins
and 2 losses and it was glad he had won
Lawson for once yes so solid play
not not remote yeah knock them out now
that super exciting event what happened
there magnets look like the clear leader
while he and Aronian were retired during
the first half of the events but chronic
was languishing six straight drawers of
7st drawers and then all of a sudden win
draw win win win whoa where did he come
from right we'll recap that one in some
future show but that one was certainly
very exciting with quite a lot of
highlights coming out of that and I
remember Peter Svidler win
that last game black yes with black
against magnets in the last round and
they can because you could just see
Magnus a team Magnus it's like being
despondent and then being told that they
had a better time lost he didn't know
that Kramnik was also at that point he
was already lost as well but he didn't
know it yeah Wow and Chuck he comes back
and plays that the game of his
tournament right after playing so badly
in the first half right but you never
know and he showed up on that last day
that was a candidates tournament for the
ages no question about it but in this
event I mean again after four rounds the
likelihood is we're gonna see three
players tied for first and the
tournament as far as I can tell is
really wide open because the players are
so together yeah well it's really close
but let's let's you know we we've
discussed this and I think it's very
important for the fans to recognize it
as well as my board is kind of acting up
over here it's important for the fans to
recognize that because of this tie break
there's some critical results that have
already occurred the first tie break
being heads ahead it means that Bing
Lauren is in trouble against Wang Hao
and Maxine Maxine by Sheila grounds
right he lost to both those players
they're currently essentially two games
ahead of him one point yes but even if
he wins and they draw then they're still
ahead of them so he has to win again and
another draw for them to be tied but
let's say that happens he wins two in a
row and they draw two in a row they're
not really tied because if that that
results stayed steady all the way to the
end of the event then ding Lauren loses
in to untie brace to Maxine and to Wang
Hao so he literally has to go more than
plus two than their result in order for
him to overtake them unless one of his
wins is against them then if then now
head-to-head is even
but if he doesn't defeat them and he
goes +2 let's say he wins 4 out of the
remaining games and that's going to be a
tall order from this moment but he goes
+4 and they go +2
he's losing on tiebreak so he would have
had a fantastic finish but he's gonna
lose on tiebreak so those two players in
particular but he is ahead of Fabi so
Fabi can't afford for him to join they
in a race for them to join in tie up as
you guys said because at the end if
they're tied and Fabi didn't defeat him
then Fabi loses I mean Chris chick for
example a few surges but not against
England he doesn't beat things and he
just surges right and ignorance surges
as well they learn does have the better
tyberg against Christian just because he
has more decisive games right so that so
the tournament is actually weird right
it's very there's a weird that because
it's not just a straightforward
interruptive because he actually just
decline the repetition I was just gonna
say 3 full repetition at the end of the
game you were Yan could have played the
move Bishop c5 claimed the draw or have
been very happy to go home and do
whatever it is he has planned the rest
of the day right but unfortunately for
him which I'm sure it's social
distancing by the way right oh come on I
got books to read you know we're
exercised in the room I'm studying some
Spanish I want to you know I want to get
all that stuff in so you're saying that
after Bishop battle by Bishop c5 was the
draw claim but instead he played Bishop
e7 inviting a mistake
what could be his mistake what how can
Fabi lose this game yeah that seems to
be my question I have no idea I mean if
he plays Bishop e5 and says no that's
fine he's good with everything that came
too far that's also completely fine
exactly exactly but but also unless huh
me know unless there's us or whatever
trickery
yeah it doesn't hurt to play the move
good only 7 you know if it's a draw to
draw maybe the guy will have a brain
cramp and do something ridiculous but
the only problem of doing that is
sometimes you're the one that has a
brain
have you done that I've done that you
play on you say let's play some more
moves I know it's a draw but we'll play
on I know that I can't really lose so
I'll just play while not lose and then
you make a move on you're like where was
my drop why didn't I just take it the
old braincraft
I like that man messing up is that like
a weakness that these all of these
players have to have they have to have
the arrogant contempt factor they have
to feel that they're superior
exactly and that then then they over
press sometimes yeah it certainly
happens to all of us I'm more worried
about fabbi in this particular case like
yesterday well not yesterday but round
three yes it's like when the two parts
accra fight as black the preparation was
amazing I mean just like like beyond
amazing it's just like ridiculously good
but then because he gets us perhaps he's
made these pawn sacrifices does he does
he think he's he's winning because I'm
going to win every game kind of attitude
I think he knew he was in a complicated
position he just tried to do the best
out of it he knew it wasn't clear it was
a position where he knew it was risky
okay he just created chances
he found the chances he wasn't able to
make much out of them right kind of
today he found chances you can't say
that he didn't exactly clear chances it
was the queen of three that spoiled look
like a great yeah opportunity for him we
got more moves okay I should get to
those after oops sorry let me just
refresh my board for a second yes there
you go and let's see the last few
minutes so we this is where never
declined the repetition with the move
Bishop e7 we're mentioning that Bishop
to c5 would have been a three timer and
then King three four this Bishop d6
played Bishop f6 played on King c7 so
this is the current position she's a
seven
okay so is he we have looked at any
attempt to sneak up the board with King
b6 and king b5 that can be met by Bishop
da check yeah but well you do have to
make a move for white but I don't see
anything wrong with Bishop g7 oh okay so
you do allow him to creepy up the ball
but Bishop e5 I think it's just a draw
another thing you can actually take this
is Bishop yeah that actually loses wow
that would be so easy to lose it just
was the Queen endgame I think B 386 and
you just yeah you're just losing the
Queen and I promote with check I'll take
one zero eight seven
yeah okay so that's the problem if you
yeah nobody if you take on e5 if you if
you go too far on the Queen side yes
five six seven but I thinking of sixth
no just kidding
oh I go King e7 of course like ready
right you don't okay oh yes you'll have
to waste another tempo and then I mean
so yeah it's like you saw you you slalom
up the board
you know you zag and zag you force black
to make a move and now you're in this so
I need a partner all looks like a draw
but is completely irrelevant because the
big move was Bishop g5 instead of Bishop
g7 okay five was played okay I'm
assuming that now you king b6 you do
want to play Bishop p8 exactly and that
looks well surprisingly okay but Maurice
for one is so very happy that the
players are just exhausted every Sunday
night I know that he loves this endgame
Oh losing over the possibility he loves
his fighting spirit right I know
Murray's us all about this kind of
positions exactly this is where he
really really gets himself all excited
all right no it's wonderful
so much going salsa dancing tonight by
the way I see you're stepping there like
let's go even if I did the place would
not be open yeah that's for sure
oh man but I but I did salsa in my room
by myself unfortunately but that's what
you gotta do you gotta stay in shape
folks you gotta stay in shape there's a
physical whatever you got to do you
might not be open but you've got to stay
physical state physical stay positive
stay productive in these days where
we're finding everybody self isolating
and quarantine are you doing streaming
it just seems to me like the whole world
and not just the chess world but the
music world as well they're doing
streaming have you seen some of these I
want to say online concert with all of
these amateur singers around the world
it's it's some stuff I've seen it's nice
I do
join twitch okay and usually I go to
either one of the chest channels or one
of the dota channels just to see what's
up because that's my game of choice
right and usually you know twitch has X
amount of people right I've been on
Twitch the last few days it's like X 5
or 6 right it's booming I mean all kinds
of video games are being played there's
like a just chat channel that just
exploded and people like talking to each
other online it's crazy
I wanted to give a shout out to
Alexandra she's hosting a tournament
which I thought was pretty cute cool
yes isolated we've isolated Queen
tournament actually pretty cool I
believe it's gonna happen at 2 p.m.
Eastern time or at 1 p.m. Central
today our social media director Eric
Rosen said he's set up kochia a lot of
strong players will be participating in
fact if abrahama who is also with us
okay I'm very often here at the club I
believe that a former world champion
under Kristin York is gonna be streaming
and playing at the same time so it
should be a little that's I mean that's
an I mean you got to be inspired inspire
I mean in these harsh times give us
something to do that was very playful
and we're done here I'll have some lunch
enough blowing past lunch time control
is only three time control but is that
30-second increment that's the key
playing keep playing Wow
okay well this one does look like it
should be a draw but Nippo says I got
anything better to do I don't want to go
isolate in the room right let's keep
playing I do want to go back to this
game though this game we could go back
to where are we let's go all the way
back we could we could be talking about
this game for months and this one was
such a huge game and this game is
something that Fabiano will remember
depending on how his result goes in this
tournament if he ends up not bringing
home the bacon he will remember this
game because his preparation with the
move e5 which is such a fabulous
incredibly interesting shot and after
the Paul was captured that this
deflecting shot with Bishop to c2 trying
to get at this D pawn with his queen but
the England said you know I could have
played safely but I just thought I
that's not my style I don't want to draw
then the c-4 move a second pawn
sacrifice and again dangler and said I'm
gonna take it and this position it it's
not clear that everything is forced here
this move Queen at five instead of going
back home with Queen c1 that showed the
audacity of the number three player in
the world ding Lorraine said I'm gonna
just see what happens I don't see a
forcing line I don't see this as being
finished let us play and the thing as
far as Bobby is concerned is he knows
he's got great initiative he's got the
lead in development the exposed white
king
but he did give up two pawns for it and
now he's got to prove it now show us
you've gotten the two pawns is it
winning or is it just initiative because
you know what happens with initiative if
you slow down you your initiative dries
up and you are in trouble and what
happened here takes takes Queen c7 all
attacking moves Bishop c5 here he had
the chance to play rook e5 he took and
it was at this moment and moved 22 again
he is still down to pawns
he's got the initiative still he's got
the Queen he's got the pieces black
knows that why can't develop so easily
where the attacking moves though what
show us bring it bring it home I move
like rookie five looks wrong Queen
before looks also possible it was this
slow move eight six that had all of us
scratching our heads what's this about
in this kind of sharp position so that
shows you you can have prep you can have
initiative but if you don't have form
it's not enough it's not enough you got
it be in the moment and play those moves
and it was ding Lorraine who showed okay
you slowed things down now I'm gonna
push you back and ended up consolidating
those two pawns and winning the game Wow
thank you for that Maurice that
remembering so two days ago I just want
to say we've got the special friend from
well we're are you Christian actually
are you Martine I'm actually in the
castle in the counts castle I'm isolated
here of course as you guys have seen in
my previous video for you just enjoying
myself listening to your commentary you
guys are doing a fantastic job as usual
and enjoying the games a lot of fun
games so far a very strange candidates
so far I want to say obviously we were
seeing some amazing preparation but at
the same time you have to beg the
question what's happening in these guys
Minds right now in these guys psyche we
everything else going on in the world
how are they keeping composed you know
that's that's the key question and I
think this is going to be the key factor
playing into the later rounds Christian
today's round especially we saw
- I think enormous missed opportunities
by MBL and fabbi - potential victories
that should what will likely end in the
draws some other missed opportunities
talk about that to be honest to be
honest I think Fabiano's missed
opportunity of course with the computer
is very easy to see but I think
practically it was a very difficult
situation to understand you have to play
this Queen d4 followed by Queen e4 block
the King back followed by Bishop before
Bishop g7 of course it's a maneuver that
whenever he's in good shape he's going
to find but if he's not and you know
Queen f3 obviously was was it was a bad
move but I think this was much less of a
missed opportunity than what MV of it he
had what 45 minutes 50 minutes yeah at
the time of the critical moment when he
was able to play a rookie for in my
opinion that was just unacceptable his
level it was just simply unacceptable to
miss the critical moment because there's
so many pieces attacked right there
there's very few options yes the
critical moment where he could have
played route to e4 I think that was
that's not like saying coach game bring
up that moment that you're describing
because that I mean we were avidly
analyzing that precise situation and it
was right here this beautiful move a for
coaxing the Knight to a4 where it is
vulnerable and here you're being very
very critical indeed Christian you're
saying rookie for um VL with all the
time you had on your clock you should
find this move go ahead well to be
honest I I think
he saw this move leading up to this
position and before he played a move a
for for whatever reason I think he just
simply forgot
immediately after Greece took to Canaan
for I think he forgot about the option
and you know got coaxed into this Bishop
III idea coax him why would you say that
it's a nice check you're going to get
it's a nice check you're going to get
your material back most likely you get
the rook on f5 very active via c5 by
force and that's visually very appealing
in my opinion but I just wanted to say
between Fabiano corona onion the
community the game has predictably
really
let's see those final moves but before
go ahead and finish your thought
Christian and then we're going to be
wrapping up very quickly you're saying
yes visually this is very attractive it
is very attractive the rook is going on
the seventh rank you're going to be our
equal points or maybe even upon up if
your opponent goes with a king to FA it
just looks visually appealing from
whites perspective to get into this
situation and you're not risking
anything at the same time finish your
calculation spend 10 15 minutes on
rookie for understand the consequences
and the plate you are a 2800 player so
just played thank you Christian for
joining us make it a habit
we'll see you guys thank you guys we'll
see you tomorrow
Maurice take us through the very final
moves and give us your final thoughts
for this fourth round where all the
games were drawn by the way I was a
bishop da check T King D 3 bishop f8
King the four Bishop d6 and the players
agreed to a draw as you said four draws
in this round a couple of real missed
opportunities there it happens in all
tournaments that the players miss their
chances they have to bounce back they
don't to just be kicking themselves at
the bounce back and say still a long way
to go we've done with for 10 more rounds
left so it should be an exciting day
tomorrow has the players play in this
unusual set under
unusual set of circumstances and I
expect more excitement you're gonna see
more missed opportunities that's just
the way chess tournaments are a lot of
pressure a lot of tension on the line
all right Thank You Maurice for that
let's take a look at our final standings
Josh it was two and a half points out of
four that's under Grichuk and five in a
Corona at 50% even though we do have a
randomized order for now because this
won't count until the end but my mana
would have this better tight break in
this position because he has more
decisis so you'd like to see the Fabian
griffix it's a flippin position there
it's just details a little bit of a
detail and true Alex anko they are
currently tied for six with one and a
half points very tight tournament one
decisive game could change everything
right from lowliest to holiest in a
single flip we do have our round and our
usual time tomorrow everybody I was just
gonna ask our producers can I take a
quick peek of what is coming up for
tomorrow's rounds and just very very
very very with the white pieces will be
facing Fabiano Caruana Alex hundred
Chris Chuck with white against England
yeah okay sorry I lied sink over the
white pieces against the metal yeah I
think that's also very big game because
the veil can score with the black pieces
that would be great if material can
score with white in the back in the
tournament and a matchup of our two
players tied for first scene that's the
one we're gonna have to focus our
attention on because this are wild
players yeah I'm Netanyahu playing
against Wang Hao Yan with the white
piece of good parents
it's very very very nice indeed and of
course we'll be starting at our regular
time here from st. Louis 8 a.m. in our
mornings so make sure to join us here
tomorrow don't miss it and spend your
Sunday with us for at least the morning
house and thank you for sharing your
weekend thus far yeah we'll be back
[Music]
[Music]